Rồi các bạn, buổi tuần trước chúng ta
đang chúng ta đã nói xong cái lý thuyết
của cái khóa này đúng không? Buổi trước
chúng ta đã dừng lại ở cái đoạn chúng ta
nói về lý thuyết của các cái hệ thống
gợi ý hay là recommendation system. Thì
hôm nay hôm nay chúng ta sẽ hôm nay
chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau chúng ta xây dựng
một cái hệ thống gợi ý ờ rất là đơn giản
thôi. Các bạn có nhớ đoán qua một chút
lại nhá.
Mở lại một chút về slide hôm nọ.
Ờ
chờ mình một xíu
đây.
Rồi đây đúng không? Sẽ sẽ đá qua lại một
chút nhá. Tầ trước chúng ta nói về
recommendation system hay là các cái hệ
thống gợi ý. Đây là những cái hệ thống
mà nó rất là quan trọng trong các cái
công ty làm về mảng B2C tức là business
to customer đấy đúng không? Tức là họ
bán sản phẩm trực tiếp đến khách hàng
thì có rất nhiều cái hệ thống gợi ý khác
nhau nhưng mà chúng th được xây dựng chủ
yếu dựa trên bốn cái mô hình cơ bản một
là
popular base system tức là những cái hệ
thống gợi ý dựa trên cái mức độ phổ biến
ví dụ như là giúp chúng ta mà vừa mới
đăng ký một cái tài khoản trên Netflix
chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì lúc này hệ
thống sẽ chưa biết gì về chúng ta. Nó
chưa chưa biết chúng ta là ai, không
biết chúng ta thích cái phim gì, cái thể
loại phim gì mà không biết một cái thông
tin gì về với chúng ta cả. Thì lúc này
hệ thống nó sẽ chỉ đơn giản, nó sẽ gợi
cho chúng ta những cái gì mà nhiều người
người ta xem đúng không? Ví dụ như cái
phim trong trading chẳng hạn. Thế đây là
popular hoặc là popular hoặc là ta phải
gọi là popularity base recommendation
system.
Các cái hệ thống này nó được cái là đơn
giản nhưng mà cái nhược điểm của nó là
gì? Cái điểm của nó là nó sẽ không có
tính cá nhân hóa. Tức là dù là mình
login hoặc là các bạn login hay là bất
kỳ ai login nó cũng sẽ đều g ý đúng cái
bộ phim như vậy.
Cái loại thứ hai là content based
featuring. Content base featuring là gì?
Content base feing là những cái hệ thống
gợi ý mà nó sẽ gợi ý cho chúng ta những
cái sản phẩm, những cái item mà tương tự
như những thứ mà chúng ta đã mua, đã
tương tác đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn xem
phim trên Netflix chẳng hạn thì hệ thống
nó sẽ gửi ý cho bạn những cái bộ phim mà
cùng cái thể loại với cái bộ phim mà các
bạn hay xem đúng không? hoặc là các bạn
mua đồ trên Amazon hoặc là eBay chẳng
hạn thì ví dụ các bạn mua các bạn đang
tìm kiếm một cái món đồ là ví dụ laptop
chẳng hạn thì hệ thống nó sẽ gửi ý cho
bạn những cái món đồ nó đồ công nghệ
giống kiểu laptop được chưa? Thế là
content based là hệ thống lọc dựa trên
hệ thống lọc dựa trên nội dung đúng
không? Nội dung tức là chính là cái sản
phẩm mà chúng ta tương tác đấy đúng
không? Và tương tác đây nó không chỉ là
chỉ là mua đâu. Tương tác có thể các bạn
cho vào giỏ hàng các bạn vì các bạn xem
các bạn ở lại các bạn xem lâu và các bạn
thả live thôi. Các bạn đánh giá năm sao
chẳng hạn. Vậy đấy cũng là tương tác.
Hệ thống này thì nó cao cấp hơn so với
popularity based recommendation system
nhưng mà nó vẫn chưa có nó có cái nó
cũng có tính cá nhân hóa nhưng mà nó
những cái gợi ý của cái hệ thống này thì
thường nó sẽ không có được đa dạng. Tức
là các bạn đã hay xem hay là các bạn hay
tương tác sản phẩm gì thì suốt đời nó
chỉ gửi cho bạn những sản phẩm như thế
thôi. Được chưa? Đây là content based
featuring. Lại tiếp theo là
ờ collaborative featuring tức là lọc
cộng tác. Lọc cộng tác có nghĩa là gì?
Tức là hệ thống nó sẽ xem là ví dụ các
bạn các bạn đã tương tác, các bạn mua,
các bạn cho vào giỏ hàng một cái sản
phẩm gì đấy thì người ta hệ thống nó sẽ
xem là những cái người mà cũng mà cũng
tương tác với cái sản phẩm gì đấy thì họ
còn hay
xem hay là họ tương tác với cái sản phẩm
gì khác nữa. Ví dụ các bạn hay nghe nhạc
của sư tùng ATP chẳng hạn thì hệ thống
chúng ta sẽ xem là những cái người khác
mà
những cái người khác mà cũng hay nghe
nhạc của sư Tom ATP ấ thì họ thì họ họ
họ nghe nhạc của ai nữa ví dụ h nghe
nhạc của của Subin Hoàng Sơn chẳng hạn
đúng không thì hệ thống nó sẽ và hệ
thống nó chưa biết nó không có thông tin
gì về việc là các bạn có thích nghe nhạc
Subin Hoàng Sơn hay không thì hệ thống
nó sẽ gợi ý cho bạn cái nhạc của Subin
Hoàng Sơn đúng không đây là hệ thống lọc
công tác hệ thống này nó cao cấp hơn so
với content base đúng
nó có nó sẽ vừa nó sẽ vừa đánh được vào
cái sự à
cái sự cá nhân hóa và nó vừa đánh được
vào cái sự đa dạng của cái gợi ý đúng
không? Vừa cá nhân hóa và vừa đa dạng.
Cái loại cuối là gì? Cái loại cuối là
chúng ta nói là hybrid. Hybrid ví dụ cái
cái kiểu đơn giản nhất là gì? Là hybrid
giữa content based featuring và ờ
collaborative featuring. Tức là vừa lọc
dựa trên nội dung vừa lọc giữ trên cộng
tác. Mỗi ông sẽ có những cái gợi ý và
mình sẽ compile mình sẽ kết hợp gợi ý
của hai ông này lại với nhau đúng không?
Đấy. Thế đấy là vài cái hệ thống gợi ý
cơ bản. Sau này người ta còn có rất
nhiều cái hệ thống gợi ý khác nữa nhưng
mà chủ yếu chúng sẽ được xây dựng dựa
trên bốn cái hệ thống cơ bản này. Được
chưa? Và thật ra thì sau này khi mà các
bạn đi làm ở công ty, ví dụ công ty bạn
có những cái hệ thống gợi ý thì thường
sẽ gần như là sẽ không bao giờ có chuyện
là các bạn vào các bạn phải sử dụng một
cái hệ thống từ đầu đâu. Mà thường là nó
công ty đã có sẵn cái hệ thống rồi và
các bạn sẽ chỉ vào các bạn phát triển,
các bạn bu up, các bạn maintain, các bạn
làm cái gì đó chứ các bạn gần như các
bạn sẽ không bao giờ có chuyện các bạn
phải phát triển từ đầu được chưa? Không
bao giờ có chuyện các bạn phải develop
from scratch. Đấy. Thế thì hôm nay chúng
ta sẽ thử chúng à cái popularity base nó
cơ bản quá.
Collaborative featuring nó sẽ hơi phức
tạp một chút. Hôm nay chúng ta sẽ tưởng
một cái loại đơn giản chúng ta làm quen
và chúng ta sẽ làm quen với content
based tức là hệ thống lọc dựa trên nội
dung. Được chưa? Rất là đơn giản thôi.
Tức là gì? Người dùng họ đã từng tương
tác với cái sản phẩm nào thì mình sẽ gửi
ý những sản phẩm tương tự cùng thể loại
với cái sản phẩm đấy. Đúng chưa?
Thì với cái bài thờ hành nay chúng ta sẽ
cần có một cái bộ dữ liệu. Bộ rượu thì
ta mình đã up trên Google Drive rồi.
Chúng ta có một cái bộ dữ liệu trên
Google Drive nó có tên là một cái folder
tên là Movie Data. Mình sẽ up lại ở trên
Zalo. Mình sẽ gửi lại trên Zalo đây nhá.
Bạn nào các mà các bạn chưa các bạn chưa
chưa lấy trên Google Drive về thì các
bạn có thể đây m mình gửi luôn trên Zalo
đây các bạn lấy luôn các bạn đỡ phải
ngồi tìm. Được chưa? Mình sẽ gửi các bạn
ba cái file này. Trong ba cái file này
một có một cái file là tên là movies.csv
CSV có một cái file tên là rating.cv và
một cái file là user.cv. Thì trong ba
cái file này ấy thì có cái file đầu với
file cuối nó rất là nhẹ. F đầu file cuối
nó chỉ có mấy trăm KB thôi nhưng mà cái
file ở giữa nó sẽ hơi nặng một chút. Cái
file rating này nó sẽ khoảng vài chục
MB. Được chưa? Nhìn qua cái tên các bạn
nhìn này. Cái file movie thì nó là nó
toàn thông cái file movie này thì nó
toàn thông tin về phim. Cái file user
này thì toàn thông tin về người xem. Còn
cái file rating này là nó thông tin là
việc là mỗi một người xem họ đánh giá
những cái phim họ từng xem như thế nào.
Thế bây giờ mình sẽ mở qua từng cái file
một các bạn nhá. Từng file một này
mình sẽ mở bằng Excel thôi. Đây đây toàn
file CSV các bạn mở bằng Excel thoải
mái. Ví dụ đây nhá. Cái file movie này
như thế này đây.
Cái file movie nó lại như thế này cho
cái này nhìn nó sẽ hơi bị à rồi mở trong
này nó sẽ hơi bị rối tại vì là vì là đây
nó phân cách dựa trên
nó bình thường nó phân cách dự dấu dấu
phẩy chẳng hạn nhưng mà đây mình lại
phân cách dự khoảng tab. Các bạn chờ
chút nhá mình mình sẽ mở mình sẽ mở
trong mình sẽ mở trong trong Python cho
nó dễ nhá. Mình tạo ra một cái script
này mình ghi làation
và mình ghi là
nghĩa gì với nhỉ? Recommendation
system nhá. Được chưa? Đấy. Thế bây giờ
mình sẽ phải mở từng cái file một. Mở
từng cái file một. File đầu tiên là
movie.cv nhá.
SPD. Nếu mà chúng ta mở ở đây này.
Này các bạn nhìn này. Các bạn mở đây các
bạn thấy là ở giữa hai cái trường lý các
bạn sẽ chỉ có ba cột thôi. Cái đây là
cái chỉ số đánh dấu hàng thì cái này
không tính được chưa? Movie id đánh từ 1
đến 2 3 4 này. Nó cái hàng đầu này thiên
này nó là chỉ cái cái chỉ số tường hàng
đánh từ 0. Cái này thì các bạn bỏ qua
các bạn nhìn nhế ba cột movie id title
về generers chưa? 1 2 3 4 5 được chưa?
Thì các bạn sẽ thấy là gì? Các bạn thấy
là giữa hai cái giữa hai các bạn sẽ thấy
là giữa hai cái giữa hai cái giá trị
liên tiếp ấy đúng không? Trong của một
hàng nó sẽ cách nhau bằng cái khoảng
trắng này. Cái khoảng này nó chính là
phím tab ấy đúng không? Khoảng này nó
chính là phím tab nó không phải là dấu
phẩy. Nó không phải là khoảng trắng
thông thường nó cũng không phải chấm
phẩy mà nó là một phím tab. Được chưa?
Phím tab. Thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ phải
mở cái file này ra. Bây giờ giả sử đây
import pandas xong rồi nhá. Data bằng
pandas này.
SP nhá. Được chưa?
Movie.
Movie data được chưa? Movie.
Được chưa? Thế nếu bây giờ ấy mình mở
cái này ra nếu mình chạy như này thôi
được chưa? Mình chỉ mở mặc định này thôi
các bạn nhìn nhá.
Đầu tiên các bạn thấy là chúng ta sẽ có
một cái chúng ta sẽ có một cái lỗi như
này. Có một cái lỗi như này.
Lỗi này có nghĩa là gì? Lỗ này có nghĩa
là à bình thường ấy khi mà các bạn dùng
cái hàm ris ấy nó sẽ có một cái tham số
gọi là encoder. Encoder đâu rồi?
Đâu ấy nhỉ?
Ở đây các bạn có th là encoding.
Encoding này thì mặc định nó sẽ dùng cái
encoding là cái bộ unicode unicode. Thế
nhưng mà cái sư bệnh nó sẽ cái nó nó
dùng cái bộ mặc định là cái UTF8 này tức
là nó đại diện cho bảng mã Unicode. Đấy.
Thế nhưng mà trong cái a file này của
chúng ta ấy nó sẽ có một vài những ký tự
đặc biệt. Một vài ký tự đặc biệt nó
không có trong cái bộ mã của của cái
UTF8 này nên là nó sẽ không có giải mã
được. không giải mãn được nên là nó báo
lỗi đây báo lỗi như này được chưa cái
này thật ra các bạn này các bạn có cái
lỗi này thì các bạn có thể ngày xưa thời
mình là ch mình sẽ phải post post lên
trên ví dụ lên trên stack over flow
chẳng hạn các bạn phải post lên các bạn
xem là cái lỗi này nó nó là lỗi gì đấy
thế nhưng mà thật ra bây giờ các bạn có
chatpt và các bạn có các bạn cũng chả
cần phải dùng đến close các bạn chỉ cần
post vào chatt cũng xong các bạn post
bất kỳ một cái aient
các bạn b công cụ ai nào thì các bạn sẽ
đều đều đều đều tìm được lỗi thôi. Thôi
thì với cái file này ấ mình sẽ phải đổi
cái bộ encoding đi. Thay vì để mặc định
là UTF8 thì mình sẽ đổi thành latin 1
cho nó sẽ không bị lỗi nữa. Được chưa?
Coding đây là
mình đang ngồi đây thì mình giải ngay
cho các bạn còn không thì đó là các bạn
gõ chatbt thì nó cũng ra thôi nhá. Latin
1 này. Được chưa? Thế các bạn làm thế
này rồi thì chạy nó sẽ không bị lỗi nữa.
Được chưa? Chạy từ này
cái gì nhỉ?
Chạy lại nhá.
Vẫn bị lỗi.
Cái lỗi này nó là vì sao? Tại vì là vừa
nãy mình và các bạn rồi cái file này ấy
cái cái khoảng phân cách giữa hai cái
trường liên tiếp nhau nó không phải là
dấu phẩy như bình thường mà nó là cái
phím tab. Thế nên là khi mà chúng ta
chúng ta không có bình thường ấy với cái
rẽ sẽ mặc định là cái phân cách nó là
dấu phẩy. Dấu phẩy
các bạn có thể dùng cái set hoặc là cái
delimiter. Đ hai cái đều được dùng cái
nào cũng được thì màn hình dùng dấu
phẩy. Thế nhưng mà của chúng ta nó không
phải dấu phẩy nó là phím tab. Thế nên là
chúng ta mà không chỉ ra cái đường cái
phân cái ký hiệu phân cách phù hợp ấy nó
sẽ bị lỗi thế này. Mình sẽ có cái ở đây
ví dụ mình dùng cái set này. X bằng cái
gì? Bằng kính tab này. Được chưa? Tab
này. Chạy thử này.
Các bạn nhìn này. Nó sẽ không bị lỗi
nữa. Được chưa? nó không bị lỗi nữa. Thì
như mình vừa nói rồi, các bạn mở ra thì
nó sẽ có
nó sẽ có bốn cột như này. Chó cột đầu nó
chỉ là chỉ số của từng phim thôi. Nó
chạy từ 0 đến m chạy từ 0. Được chưa?
Cái thứ hai là movie id chạy từ 1 thì
thật ra là hai ông này nó chỉ đơn giản
là ông sau bằng ông trước cộng 1 thế
thôi. Được chưa? Và nó chỉ dùng để nó đ
phân biệt ông này với ông kia các cái
phim khác nhau. Được chưa? Hai cột quan
trọng nhất là cột title với cột
generous. Title là tiêu đề của bộ phim
và generous là cái thể loại của bộ phim
đó đúng không? Một phim nó có thể nó
thuộc về nhiều thể loại đúng không? Nó
thuộc về animation đúng không? Tức là
gì nhỉ? Hoạt họa đúng không? Tren phim
cho phim cho trẻ con đúng không? Comedy
là phim hài được chưa? Adventure là phim
phum mạo hiểm đúng không? Fantasy là
phim thần tiên kiểu kiểu như vậy. Được
chưa? Thế thì đây là cái file về các cái
về các cái về các cái phim được chưa? Về
các cái bộ phim. Thế chúng ta có cái
file thứ hai là file về user. User là
người xem phim ấy đúng không? Thì mình
đổi đây đi. User này được chưa? User này
mình chạy thử nhá.
User nhá.
Đây như thế này. Tại vì user thì các bạn
thấy là chúng ta cũng có cái trường đầu
tiên là cái trường chỉ số được chưa? Rồi
ID cũng vậy đúng. ID đây thì các bạn
nhìn vào chỉ biết để phân biệt giữ ông
này với ông kia thôi chứ cho không biết
tên họ là cái gì đúng không? Gender là
giới tính đúng không? Kia là generals là
thể loại đúng không? Đây gender là giới
tính đúng không? F female là nữ, m là
male là nam. Được chưa? H tuổi là bao
nhiêu tuổi? Được chưa? Đây là cái mã của
nghề nghiệp đúng không? Occupation là
nghề nghiệp đúng không? Cái mã của cái
nghề đấy. Zip code là cái vị trí kiểu
đóng zip code là zip code thôi đúng
không? Mã bưu điện được chưa? Mô tả của
tuổi đây là dưới 18 tuổi này đúng không?
Đây là mô tả về mô tả về công việc đúng
không? Occupation description được chưa?
Tự làm đúng không? Tức là họ không đi
làm cho công ty, họ tự làm, tự mở doanh
nghiệp chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy đúng
không? Đấy. Thì đây là thông tin về về
người xem cũng có nhiều phết đấy đúng
không? Chúng ta có khoảng hơn 6000
người. Được chưa? Với cái file về movie
có bao nhiêu ấ nhỉ?
Movie có bao nhiêu? Chưa kịp xem.
Đây movie đây.
Phim thì có gần 4000 người xem thì có
trên 6000 đúng không? Tất nhiên không
phải là người xem nào cũng xem tất cả
các bộ phim đúng không? Có thể có những
người người ta xem nhiều, người ta xem
phim ít phim. Đúng chưa? [khịt mũi] Thế
bây giờ chúng ta sẽ xem tiếp cái file
cuối cùng là cái file nó nặng nhất chính
là cái file rating. Rating là cái file
nặng nhất ở đây.
A này load thì nó sẽ lâu. Load nó sẽ lâu
tại vì là nhiều mà nó
mấy chục mê thì nó sẽ rất là nhiều
rating nhá.
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Điểm qua xem này. Về
rating ấy chúng ta sẽ có khoảng
hơn 1 triệu dòng. Hơn 1 triệu dòng đúng
không? Hơn 1 triệu dòng là mỗi một dòng
sẽ là một cái đánh giá của một người nào
đấy với một bộ phim nào đấy. Được chưa?
Nhìn qua một tí nhá. Cái cột đầu vẫn là
cột chỉ số đánh bình thường. Không có
cái gì đặc biệt cả. Được chưa? Cái cột
đánh chỉ số của từng người record thôi.
User ID. Đây là user ID số 1. Cái ông số
1 đã xem từ này phim được chưa? Movie id
của bộ phim ông này xem đây. Rating ông
này đánh từ mấy? Từ 1 đến 5. N là cao
nhất, 1 là bé nhất. Được chưa? Time
stem. Time stem. Đây là nhãn thời gian.
Con số này có ý nghĩa gì các bạn? Nhãn
thời gian như này nó có ý nghĩa gì?
Nhãn thời gian như này bình thường nó là
mấy giờ? Mấy phút, mấy giây đúng không?
Giờ phút, giây ngày tháng năm. Nhưng mà
đây nó có một cái chuỗi này cũng có
nghĩa là gì các bạn?
Chuỗi này có ý nghĩa gì? 9
9.783.000
bạn 700 978.3760
stamp này cái nhãn thời gian này nó có ý
nghĩa gì? Có ai biết cái này có nghĩa gì
không các bạn?
Không ai biết.
Bạn nào học IT chắc phải biết cái này
chứ các bạn ngành khác thì không làm gì.
Bạn nào học bạn nào là sinh viên IT bạn
phải biết cái này chứ.
Gần đúng rồi.
Gần đúng rồi. Con số này nó là cái chuỗi
số này là cái gì? Đây là số giây đã trôi
qua kể từ ngày mùng 01 tháng
năm 1970 đúng không? 0 gi. Đây là số
giây đã trôi qua kể từ 0:0 giây ngày
mùng 01 tháng năm 1970 đúng không? Đây
gọi UNIC time stem nhìn nhá.
Đây nhá.
Các bạn nhìn thử nhá.
Ừ
đây nhá.
Copy nhá. Được chưa? Mình paste vào đây
này. Convert nhá. Được chưa?
Đây cái thời điểm này nó là gì? Nó là
ngày chủ nhật ngày 31 tháng 12 năm 2000
và 22:12 giây ở mối giờ số 0 là mối giờ
cái đài bă Greenwick ở Anh đấy đúng
không? Greenwick ở Anh đấy đúng không?
Đấy còn hiện nay các bạn nhìn này. X nó
cứ cộng thêm 1 đây này đúng không? Đã
bao nhiêu giây trôi qua kể từ ngày mùng
1 tháng năm 1970 rồi đúng không? Nó trôi
qua là 1 tỷ 781
triệu 349.000
97 giây. Được chưa? Đấy, thay vì các bạn
phải viết là giờ phút giây ngày tháng 5
thì các bạn viết như này.
Để làm gì? Lắm này để làm gì? Để chúng
ta có thể dễ ra chúng ta đồng bộ giữa
các múi giờ. Thế có phải là bình thường?
Bình thường khi mà các bạn ghi kiểu giờ
phút giây ngày tháng năm ấy nó không có
múi giờ. Tôi không biết là giờ phút giây
đến ngày tháng năm đấy nó là ở nó là ở
khung giờ nào đâu. Và các bạn sẽ tốn
công các bạn phải format sang cái dạng
khác. Và các bạn chú ý là gì? Máy móc
bình thường ấy các bạn cứ để ở s ngày
tháng 5 nó không có hiểu đúng không? Nó
tại vì giờ 2 chấm phút 2 chấm giây nó
đâu có hiểu cái dấu hai chấm đâu. Đây là
cách để người ta quy về cái dạng nào máy
có thể hiểu được đúng không? Máy đ nó
chỉ một cái chuỗi số thôi máy nó sẽ hiểu
ngay được chưa? Và các bạn sẽ dễ dàng
các bạn đồng bộ giữa các cái hệ thống
trên thế giới hơn đúng không? Hệ thống
này với hệ thống kia. Bây gi tôi không
biết biết mối giờ tôi cứ quýết về đây
đúng không? Đưa về mối giờ cộng 0 đúng
không? Và bao nhiêu giây đã trôi qua
đúng không? đồng bộ giữa hai máy rất là
dễ được chưa?
Đúng. Cái bạn nào học IT chắc chắn các
bạn phải biết cái này đúng không? Chắc
chắn phải biết cái này đúng không? Làm
sao các bạn học cái môn hệ thống thông
tin các thứ sao các bạn không biết này
được đ không nhá. Thì đấy là ý nghĩa của
cái cột à time stamp này được chưa? Tiếp
các bạn có cái cột
à à chưa use cái này không không cần
quan tâm lắm để movid đây là cái ID của
cái bộ phim đấy đúng không các bạn? Chỉ
quan tâm gì là ông nào xem cái phim nào
và đánh giá là bao nhiêu đúng không? và
thời gian đúng không? Đây bốn cái cột
dỗi này. Ờ user ID, movie iding với cả
time stamp là những cột quan trọng nhất.
Còn cái cột đầu tiên cột chỉ số cũng
không cần quan trọng tại vì là nó chả để
làm gì, nó chỉ phân biệt các cái record
với nhau thôi. Hai c cuối cũng không
quan trọng lắm. Được chưa?
Tất nhiên với cái bài hôm nay thì chúng
ta sẽ chỉ cần dùng cái bộ đầu tiên là à
chưa chỉ cái file đầu tiên là cái file
movie.v là đủ rồi đúng không? Chúng ta
không cần phải động đến mấy file kia.
Hai cái file kia nó nó chỉ có ý nghĩa
khi mà các bạn xây dựng cái
collaborative featuring ấ lọc cộng tác
ấy thì các bạn sẽ cần phải có cả cái
file rating với cái file của user nữa.
Nhưng mà với cái content b thì các bạn
chỉn mỗi cái movie là thừa rồi. Được
chưa?
Bây giờ nhá
mình dùng cái movie nhá.
Chạy lại này.
Chạy lại nhá.
Movie đây. Thì các bạn nhìn này với cái
file này như mình đã nói rồi đúng không?
Thật ra chúng ta chỉ cần đúng hai cột
cuối thôi là cột title với cột genders
đúng không? Tên phim và thì cái thủy lại
phim. Còn hai cột đầu nó chả có ý nghĩa
gì không cho bỏ qua cũng được đúng
không?
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Thì bây giờ ờ bình thường ấy với các cái
hàm read read các thứ của Pandas ấy
các cái hàm liên quan đến đọc của của
của Patas ấy. Nếu các bạn mà các bạn
muốn đọc hết các cột thì nó làm gì?
Nhưng nếu các bạn chỉ muốn đọc một vài
cột thôi thì các bạn có thể thêm một cái
số cuối là gì? Use column này bằng cái
gì?
Các bạn sẽ chỉ vào một cái list này và
các bạn sẽ chỉ ra cái tên của cột mà các
bạn muốn lấy. Các bạn muốn cột title với
cả generals. Được chưa? Title và general
được chưa? Các bạn có hai cột như này.
Được chưa? Title với genders. Bây giờ
mình sẽ đúng không? Mình use column được
chưa? Tôi chỉ lấy hai cột này thôi. Chạy
này.
Được chưa?
Bạn chỉ có hai cột này thôi, title với
cả genders. Được chưa? Title thì là tên
của phim còn general là các cái thể
loại. Được chưa? Các bạn lấy đúng hai
cột cần thôi. Được chưa? Ý tưởng của
mình là gì? Là bây giờ nhá, ở đây mình
có tổng cộng là mình có khoảng
gần 4000 bộ phim đúng không? Thì bây giờ
cái nhiệm vụ của mình là gì? Là bây giờ
mình muốn xây dựng một cái hệ thống ngự
ý hay là một cái recommendation system
để làm sao sau này ấ nếu mà người dùng
họ xem một cái bộ phim bất kỳ, mình giả
sử cái bộ phim họ xem ấy sẽ chỉ nằm
trong cái list. gần 4000 phim này thôi.
Được chưa? Bộ phim mà họ xem nó chỉ nằm
trong cái list gần 4000 phim này thôi.
Thì bây giờ
khi mà mình muốn là sau này khi mà người
dùng họ xem một cái bộ phim trong này ấy
thì hệ thống của mình sẽ phải gửi ý cho
họ top có thể là top 20, top 10, top 30
cái bộ phim mà nó sẽ có thể là họ sẽ
quan tâm đúng không? Có thể là họ sẽ
quan tâm đấy. Đúng không? người dùng cho
input là một bộ phim chúng ta sẽ phải
đưa ra cái list top 10 20 30 bộ phim mà
có thể họ họ quan tâm được chưa? Đấy
nhiệm vụ là như thế thôi. Được chưa?
Đây sau này chúng ta sẽ có một cái chỗ
in input là tên của một của một cái bộ
phim bất kỳ. Ví dụ các bạn mình có phim
Solas này năm 1999 chẳng hạn đúng không?
Cho input là như vậy và sau đó Ôi sorry
các bạn sorry các bạn mình lợi tay mình
ấn mình tắt in. Rồi
chờ mình một xíu mình mở lại nhá.
Đây mở lại đây. Được chưa? Đấy thì bây
giờ mình muốn là bây giờ sau này người
dùng họ có một cái bộ phim đầu vào là
mình sẽ gửi ý cho họ những cái phim mà
có thể họ sẽ quan tâm nhất. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ bây giờ cl cho mình hỏi nhá.
Bây giờ mình đọc được cái file giữa đồ
vào này rồi đúng không? đọc hai rượu này
đầu bài này rồi thế bây giờ
các bạn cho mình hỏi này bây giờ câu hỏi
mình là bây giờ nhiệm vụ của mình tức là
gì? Nhiệm vụ tổng quát mình sẽ là mình
phải đánh giá xem mức độ tương đồng giữa
hai bộ phim đúng không? Tức là cái bài
toán là bây giờ người dùng họ họ xem một
bộ phim rồi mình sẽ phải tính ra xem
những bộ phim nào nó tương đồng nhất bộ
phim đó rồi mình sẽ gợi ý họ đúng không?
Thì bây giờ cái câu hỏi là
làm sao để tôi có thể tôi đánh ra được
cái sự tương đồng ra hai bộ phim? Ở đây
mình có hai thông tin, mình có hai cột
là cột title và cột genders là cái tên
phim, tiêu đề phim đấy. Và cái thể loại.
Theo các bạn bây giờ tôi muốn đánh giá
sự tương đồng, sự tương đồng giữa hai bộ
phim thì tôi nên dựa vào cái title hay
tôi nên dựa vào general hay tôi nên dựa
vào cả hai. Tôi nên dựa vào cái gì?
và cái gì đây? Và cả hai gi có generals
nào. Title thì là tiêu đề, generals thì
là thể loại. Title cộng với general là
cả tiêu đề cả thể loại. Theo các bạn dựa
vào cái gì?
Các bạn khác thì sao?
Hầu hết các bạn đều bảo là dựa vào
trers, dựa vào thể loại. Thông thường
thì đúng là người ta cũng hay dựa vào
thể loại thật. Thông thường đúng là khi
mà dân sự tươ nồng ra bộ phim ấy cái dễ
nhất là người ta cũng sẽ dựa vào thể
loại đúng không? Thế bây giờ các bạn cho
mình hỏi này. Theo các bạn
vì sao người ta lại ưa chuộng cái việc
là người ta dựa vào thể loại hơn là
title trong việc là dự đoán sự tương
đồng giữa hai bộ phim? Title thì nó có
vấn đề gì?
Vì sao người ta không dựa vào title? Vì
sao người ta thường người ta ít khi dựa
vào title? Ít khi thôi, mình cũng không
dám khẳng định là không nhưng mà ít khi
người ta dựa vào thay thú.
Có lý do gì không?
Trung trung quá.
Title có thể dẫn đến misleading, dẫn đến
hiểu nhầm nhưng mà trúng chung quá.
Thái đầu có nhiều ý nghĩa
nhưng
có bạn nào chỉ cho mình cái cái điều gì
người ta khiến ta không dựa vào title
không các bạn?
Một khí cũng hay này. Titel nó không nói
lên được chủ đề cụ thể của phim. Ừ. Thế
nhưng mà mình đã có cái cột chủ đề rồi.
Ví dụ mình kết hợp cả hai thì sao? So
bản chất dữ liệu chung chung quá các
bạn. Do bản chất dữ liệu chung chung quá
biết gọi là bản chất dữ liệu.
Title có cái vấn đề gì các bạn?
Phức tạp. Có những tìm đơn giản lắm đây
này. Nixon này tên rất là đơn giản đúng
một từ.
Tên thì cũng đơn giản mà các bạn.
Carington này
vì sao một cái lý do ví dụ lý do là gì?
Các bạn có thể thấy là tên phim họ
thường họ họ hãy dùng tên riêng đúng
không? Tên riêng nó nó đâu nói lên cái
gì đâu. Tom và Jerry qua biết là có ý
nghĩa gì đâu. Nó dựa vào tên riêng nó
gọi đấy rất nhiều tên riêng này
đúng không? Đó đâu rồi?
Reart 3 này. Được chưa?
Gì nữa?
Đâu rồi?
Mr. Wrong chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy đúng
không?
Tên của bộ phim thì
tên của Ừ đấy cũng là một lý do đúng
không? Nhiều khi là hai cái tên nó rất
là gần nhau nhưng mà nội dung nó chả
liên quan gì đến nhau cả đúng không? Tên
phim thì thường Tên phim thì thường
người ta đặt ra cái tên với mục đích là
gì? Để người ta làm sao người ta thu hút
khán giả đúng không? Tên thì nghe nó
phải nó phải catchy nhiều khi nó phải
ngắn gọn đúng không? Cái tên làm sao để
nó hút được khán giả đúng không? Cái tên
nhiều khi nó không phản ánh cái ý nghĩa
của bộ phim mà nó chỉ nó hút thôi là nó
ok rồi đúng không?
Thế còn cái thể loại phim? Nó sẽ phản
ánh trung thực cái nội dung của phim đó
đúng không? Thể loại nó sẽ phản ánh
trung thực của cái phim của đó. Thế còn
các bạn cái tên phim thì các bạn có rất
nhiều cái tên phim nó toàn tên riêng
thôi. Sabrina này đúng không? Tomen Hug
này đúng không? Dracula, Battle Nixon
này đúng không? Tên riêng nó chả có ý
nghĩa gì cả. được chưa? Rumanji chẳng
hạn đúng không? Đấy mình chủ yếu mình sẽ
rùa vào general. Tất nhiên nếu các bạn
thấy là các bạn có một cái lý do thì các
bạn thấy là một cái lý do rất là vức
chắc để các bạn dùng title thì các bạn
cứ dùng thì cũng được nhưng mà thông
thường người ta sẽ ít khi người ta dùng
title. Thông thường tại vì các bạn các
hiểu này trong title với cả general ấy,
title là cái thứ chủ quan con người có
thể ảnh hưởng đến. Còn general thì
không. Cái title này được quyết định bởi
cái ông cái ông viết kịch bản. Được
chưa? Ông viết k bản ông đấy ông ấy
thích đặt tên gì thì được thì cũng được
nhưng cái general ông đấy không tự quyết
được mà sẽ dựa vào cái nội dung ông ấy
viết ra ông ấy viết ra nội dung gì nó sẽ
thuộc vào cái general đấy được không nó
sẽ khách quan hơn được chưa cái gì mà
con người càng ít can thiệp vào được ấy
thì nó càng càng tin cậy được chưa và
channel thì cái ý tưởng nó đơn giản lắm
bây giờ làm sao để trong này bây giờ có
một cái bộ phim mà người dùng họ xem nhá
đúng không ví dụ người dùng họ xem cái
phim nxon rồi chẳng hạn đúng không
ví dụ họ xem cái phim
Phim phim Crot Iceland này C is Iceland
này được chưa? Phim này nó có thể loại
như này action này adventure romance
được chưa? Thì bây gi có ba thở này. Bây
giờ tôi phải tìm xem là trong cái list
của gần 4000 bộ phim này đâu là top của
10 hay là 20 cái bộ phim mà mà có cái
thể loại tương đồng nhất với thể loại
này là sau được chưa?
Thì tôi sẽ dựa vào thể loại thì bây giờ
nói xem là tôi sẽ xử lý những cái thể
loại này như nào thì các bạn thấy là có
một cái điểm chú ý đây là gì? Ở đây có
những cái thể loại này nó có những phim
có nhiều thể loại được chưa? Có phim
nhiều thể loại này đúng không? Thì bây
giờ làm sao tôi phải tách chúng ra? Tách
chúng ra thì làm thế nào? Thì các bạn
cho mình hỏi nhá. Thế bây giờ theo các
bạn bây giờ bây giờ tôi sẽ đánh giá cái
sự tương đồng của hai bộ phim. Tôi biết
là tôi dựa vào cái thể loại rồi đúng
không? Thế bây giờ mà cụ thể tôi sẽ làm
thế nào? Cụ thể ví dụ tôi các bạn thấy
là hai cái bộ phim này nó chung nhau cái
truy thì chắc chắn chúng ta phải gần gũi
hơn là cái phim đầu với cả cái ví dụ cái
phim phim hai phim đầu đầu tiên đúng
không? Chúng nó có mỗi ông có ba thể
loại đúng không? Hai này hai này chỉ
giống nhau cái trent thôi. Thế nhưng mà
chắc chắn chúng nó như vậy nó sẽ phải
giống như tương đồng nhau hơn là cái
phim đầu này về cái action đúng không?
Đầu action animation comedy với action
nó chả liên quan đến nhau cả. Được chưa?
Rõ ràng là hai bộ phim đầu tiên nó phải
tương đồng nhau hơn là cái bộ phim đầu
với cái bộ phim
có cái chỉ số là 8 này. Thế bây giờ cụ
thể làm sao để mình có thể mình đánh giá
được cái sự tương nồng đấy? Làm sao mình
đánh giá cái sự tương đồng giữa hai bộ
phim bây giờ? The B changers làm nào bây
giờ?
Làm nào bây giờ?
Ừ càng như thế lại càng càng đầu tiên.
Nhưng mà mình sẽ các bạn các bạn định
làm nào các bạn định làm vòng lập à
bạn đị làm nào các bạn định làm cái vòng
lập for à?
Góm nào nhóm á không ổn. Một phim có thể
thuộc về nhiều nhóm ngay phim đầu tiên
nó có thể thuộc về ba nhóm khác nhau.
Các bạn định cho nó vào nhóm nào bây giờ
cho nó bảo nhóm animation tren hay là
comedy bây giờ
sự tầm ra bộ phim bây giờ.
One hot one hot á.
One hot.
Cái này on hot thì sẽ không ổn. Onehot
ấy thì các bạn sẽ phải coi cả cái cụm
này là một thể loại đúng không? One hot
là các bạn chỉ có một vectơ khác 0 à một
con số khác 0 thôi. Đây ví dụ các bạn
muốn thành ba ba số khác 0 nó sẽ không
làm được.
đã phân ra cái gender thành các cái pin
thì
word meding á
cũng là một cách nhưng mà thế thì các
bạn mà dùng wording ấy thì ví dụ ông này
nó có ba thể loại các bạn định dùnging
kiểu gì đây cái này nó có ba thể loại
các bạn dùng kiểu gì bây giờ nó chỉ
wording cho từng loại thôi nó không nó
các cái mô hình ví dụ như glob là fast
chẳng hạn nó không ing đồng thời đâu chỉ
nó được từng một cái thôi tính điểm gì
mới được chứ
Tính điểm nhưng mà điểm gì mới được
chưa?
Tính điểm nhưng điểm gì mới được chưa?
Điểm gì bây giờ các bạn tính điểm gì?
Adventure trece sẽ là animation với cả
comedy này. Tính điểm tính điểm kiểu gì?
Không nghĩ là cái nào?
Về cho hai bộ phim. Mỗi bộ phim nó có nó
thuộc một hoặc là một vài cái thể loại
này các bạn chịu chết không nào tính
được cái sự từ nồng về mặt thể loại của
chúng.
Mình nghĩ sẽ thể hiện nội dung bằng
feature xong người đánh nhãn cho từng
feature
có con người ngồi đánh nhãn á không
được. Recommendation system là bài toán
unsupervice. Các bạn nhớ chúng ta học từ
những cái buổi đầu ấy đúng không? Chúng
ta có supervise với cả reinforce
learning đúng không? Trong superv các
bạn có classification và regression.
Trong uns các bạn có class các bạn có
clustering có v các bạn có các bạn có
association thì cái recommend system này
nó chính là bài toán association đấy.
Bài toán un nó không có nhãn cis á.
C nearis
Ceris thì cũng là một cách đấy như mà
các bạn các bạn muốn dùng cis các bạn
phải phóng nó vào trong không gian n
chiều xong các bạn phóng kiểu gì bây giờ
animation company các bạn phóng kiểu gì
bây giờ bao này nó dính vào nhau này các
bạn đưa vào không gian kiểu gì các bạn
đâu thể dùng chữ mà các bạn dùng cate
được đúng cây unitate là trong không
gian nó phải không gian dạng số nên đây
không phải số quái đâu.
Học rồi chúng ta quên hết rồi. Chúng ta
dùng gì?
DF IDF
học rồi mà học chán ra rồi đúng không?
Hôm trước thực hành chán rồi xong mấy
mấy mấy buổi không dùng thì đã quên rồi.
TF IDF nhưng mà trước khi các bạn muốn
dùng TFDF ấ IDF các bạn phải tách tương
mấy ông này ra đúng không? bỏ mấy cái
khoảng bỏ mấy cái dấu sọc này đi các bạn
thay nó bằng khoảng trắng chẳng hạn đúng
không? Thì các bạn mới có thể các bạn
dùng TF IDF được đúng không? Thì bây
giức là bây giờ mình muốn áp dụng mình
muốn apply mình bây giờ mình muốn sửa
cái cột gener này làm sao tôi thay cái
dấu sổ dọc này bằng cái khoảng trắng
đúng không? Ví dụ tôi lại dùng cái hàm
apply thôi. Đây các bạn nhìn nhá.
Tiếp nọ chúng ta học chán ra rồi mà thực
hành cũng chán ra rồi đúng không?
Movie à data được chưa? General này được
chưa? Bằng data gener
được chưa? Chấm apply.
L này cái hàm nó đơn giản mình có thể
dùng hàm lamda lamda s này được chưa?
S.rece
replace cái dấu sổ dọc này
khoảng tránh như này.
Được chưa?
Đây đẹp rồi. Đây này. Đúng không? Cái
dấu sổ dọc mất rồi. Nó còn khoảng trắng
thôi. Được chưa? Sau này bây giờ sẽ dùng
TF IDF nhá. TF IDF thì bây giờ chúng ta
lại
import thôi đúng không? Form learn đúng
không? Feature extraction text. Đây TF
IDF này được chưa? Mình sẽ áp dụng cái
TF IDF và cái cột general này chưa? Dưới
nhá. Vectorizer
này. Được chưa? Gì nhỉ? Bây giờ mình gọi
là idf magic đi bằng vectorizer
fit fish transform general.
Ví dụ như này nhá. Được chưa?
Form nhá. Xem nó như nào nhá.
nó sẽ hơi à cũng không
mình sẽ mình sẽ in ra cái shap của cái
màn trận này nhá.
Print này tdmic.shave
sh nhá. Được chưa?
Các bạn nhìn này, nó có
nó có 3883 hàng và nó có 20 cột đúng
không? 3883 là số hàng, số record đấy
đúng không? Số record trong cái file
movie này. Còn số cột là số lượng các
cái thể loại khác nhau. Được chưa? Như
bây giờ mình mình có thể mình sẽ mình
muốn in nó thanh ra thành một cái thành
một cái ma trận chẳng hạn nhìn cho nó dễ
đúng không? Thì mình có thể mình à tại
vì các bạn nhìn thấy ở đây chúng ta
chúng ta chưa có xem nó được. Ví dụ mình
muốn xem nó trông xem mặt mũi như nào.
Đây các bạn nhìn thấy không? Nó là một
cái ma trận này chúng ta sẽ
ta sẽ chưa xem được. Chưa xem được đâu.
Nó là nó nó là cái dạng thưa. Nó spice
này nó là cái dạng thưa. Bây giờ mình
muốn xem được ấ mình phải đưa nó về cái
dạng à dạng dance. Cái dạng mà à cái
dạng mà nó cái dạng truyền thống mà nó
tức là có rất nhiều số 0 đấy đúng không?
Danse là cái dạng có rất nhiều số 0. Mà
spa là nó chỉ ra những chỗ nào nó khác
không mà thôi. Thế bây giờ mình có thể
mình sẽ convert nó thành một cái ma trận
dance như vậy nhá. Thf IDF
matric này đen
bằng t
đây mình dùng cái hàm to dance này đưa
thành từ ma trận thưa thành ma trận
dance. Được chưa? Mình có thể đặt tên
của các cái cột nữa.
Tên của các cái cột thì nó sẽ là tên của
các cái
sẽ là tên của các cái feature các bạn
nhìn nhá. Print này. Vectorizer này
chấm
in cái vocaby. Ừ ra cái vocabulary đi.
Đây nhá.
Animation này, jadden này, comedy này.
Đấy,
có từ này thể loại nhá. Mình sẽ copy
paste cho các bạn. Các bạn xem thử nhá.
Ở đây nhìn qua là mình có 20 thể loại ở
đây. Mình có 20 thể loại mình gửi các
bạn trong cái đoạn chat này. Mình có 20
thể loại cái chỉ này nó nó chỉ là cái vị
trí của nó trong cái vocabulary thôi.
Đúng mà ông nào càng gần A thì nó càng
lên gần 0. Ông nào cần gần Z nó càng gần
số cuối đúng không? Các bạn nhìn qua cái
list này gồm 20 thể loại này. Các bạn có
phát hiện ra cái điểm gì không? Các bạn
có nhận xét gì không?
Các bạn có nhận xét gì không?
Có ai có nhận xét gì không?
Mình gửi cho bạn cái list 20 cái thể
loại này các bạn có nhận xét gì không?
Nó không random đâu các bạn ạ. Nó đâu có
random đâu. Mình nói rồi cái vị trí cái
các cái con số này nó thể hiện cái vị
trí nó trong cái vocaby thôi đúng không?
Nó sẽ theo ừ nó sẽ theo ABC mà nó đâu có
random đâu. Theo ABC đâu. Ông nào cứ
càng gần ABC nó càng số nó bé chỉ số nó
bé. Còn ông nào gần X YZ chỉ số nó nó
lớn thôi đúng không? Không phải không
phải random đâu.
Nhìn kỹ nào. Quay có nhận xét gì không.
À đây này các bạn nhìn ra rồi. Đây này
có số 16 về số 9 đúng không? Chúng ta có
có chúng ta có một cái thờ loại là s
fiction. S fiction tiếng Việt mình là
cái gì các bạn? S fiction nó thể loại
gì?
Sun fiction nó là gì nhở? Khoa học viễn
tưởng. Đúng rồi. Khoa viễn tưởng đúng
không?
Vì sao lại bị tách như vậy? Chúng ta
nhìn nhá. Vì sao lại bị tách như vậy?
Ừ nó là khoa học viễn tưởng đấy đúng
không? Nó nó chính là khoa học viễn
tưởng đấy đúng không? Đây này. Sion này
đúng không? Tại vì sao? Tại vì nó ngăn
cách bởi cái bởi cái dấu trừ này. Và khi
chúng ta dùng TF IDF ấy thì TFIDF nó coi
dấu trừ cũng như giống như là khoảng
trắng nó là cái những cái ký tự để phân
cách các cái từ ra. Thế nên là nó phân
tách ra đúng không? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
để bây giờ mình tránh là cái tiếp id nó
nó bị nhìn sai như vậy thì tôi thể tôi
sẽ xóa dấu trừ luôn thôi. Sion tôi sẽ
viết liền với nhau. Được chưa? Ngoài cái
session nó còn có một cái nữa cơ. Nó còn
có một cái nữa là cái a
có một cái nữa cái a
đây này. Nó có một thể nữa là phim noi.
Cái phim này thì
nó là cái thể loại phim a phim tội phim
không hẳn là phim tội phạm nhưng mà đây
chả biết dịch Mình sẽ nó là phim kiểu
kiểu như này cũng không phải là tội phạm
nhưng mà nó là cái kiểu mà
đây nó kiểu kiểu như này đấy. Mình cũng
không biết dịch cái bạn phim đen thì
cũng giả cũng không không không cũng
không không lắm thế nhưng mà đây nó là
cái phim kiểu kiểu như này.
Đấy được chưa? Cái phim nó này nó cũng
là một cái thể loại phim nhưng mà đây nó
có cái dấu trừ này mà nó bị bị tách ra
làm hai nó tách ra làm hai.
Thế thì bây giờ mình sẽ bây giờ mình sẽ
đổi tiếp ở đây đúng khôngạ? chấm replace
à chấm replay này
hay khoảng này như thế này được chưa thì
bây giờ làm như vậy mình xem còn trước
là mình có trước là mình có 20 đúng
không bây giờ này khả năng cao mình sẽ
còn có 18 thôi
này nhá
sun fishion này được một thể loại này
được chưa phim được một thể loại này nhớ
là gì tiếp mặc định là nó sẽ lower case
tức là các bạn sẽ đưa hết hình chữ viết
thường nó vi với thường hết các bạn sẽ
còn khoảng 18 thôi
sau mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ
mình sẽ in ra mình sẽ in mình sẽ in ra
một cái data frame như này to này được
chưa bây giờ mình chạy thử nhá mình sẽ
in
mình sẽ in thử cái ma trận magic ra nhé
nhá.
Cái ma trận thưa thì mình không in được.
Ma trận thưa thì không in được đây. Ma
trận thưa thì không in được này. Nhưng
mà chạ kia thì xem được. Đây các bạn
thấy chưa? Nó có 18 hàng thôi. Đấy từ 0
đến à nó có 18 cột từ 0 đến 17 này. Được
chưa? Cái ông đầu nó có ba thể loại cái
gì? Animation với cả cái gì? Fantasy à
cái gì đấy đúng không? Đấy nó như này
được chưa?
Các bạn có đúng 18 cột và các bạn có 383
hàng ch đánh chỉ số tất cả đều đánh chỉ
số từ 0 cả cột và hàng đều đánh chỉ số
từ 0.
Ờ nếu mà hàng với cột như này các bạn
thấy chỉ số đánh toàn số này các bạn
nhìn nó sẽ hơi bị khó tại vì tôi không
biết là ví dụ cái hàng này đi các bạn
thay nó là tên của phim đi thì sẽ rất là
dễ hoặc cột các bạn thấy tay thay tên nó
là cái thể loại đi nhìn rất là dễ đúng
không? Hàng là tên phim, cột là tên thể
loại thì nhìn nó sẽ rất là dễ. Nhưng mà
ở đây thì mình lại
ở đây thì các bạn thấy là nó tàn số này
nhìn rất là khó đúng không? Thì bây giờ
mình có thể mình sẽ thay nó đi. Mình
thay đi là gì? Bây giờ mình sẽ thay đổi
tên hàng, mình sẽ thế cái tên hàng không
phải là số nữa mà nó dùng đúng tên phim
luôn. Cột mình sẽ lấy đúng là cái số
lượng các cái feature luôn. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ các bạn nhìn nhá. Bây giờ ở
đây cái cái data frame này mình sẽ thêm
cái nữa là gì? Cái column
bằng gì? dùng là ờ
data
sẽ dùng cái a
mình sẽ dùng cho các bạn mình dùng cái
vizer này
sẽ lấy tên của những cái feature mà nó
lấy ra được đúng không? Chính là những
cái trên cái thể loại phim đấy. Get
feature
name như này. Metzerizer
đâu nhỉ?
Thiếu một cái ngoặc ngoài
advure name này. Được chưa? Đây là tên
của cột. Advure name này nó là nó sẽ trả
về chúng ta tên của 18 cái cột đấy. Tên
của 18 cái feature mà 18 cái thể loại
đấy. Được chưa? Đây là tên cột. Còn tên
hàng thì mình chỉ tên hàng mình chỉ lấy
đơn giản là mình lấy tên phim thôi. Được
chưa?
index này. Index thì bằng data a này sẽ
lấy cái tên phim là title
được chưa? Tên cột thì là tên các cái
thể loại còn tên hàng chứ tên phim chạy
thử này. Lúc trước là như này nhá. Được
chưa? Lúc trước là cả hàng cả cột ta đều
là số cả đúng không? Mình thay này
ơ get feature name.
Ờ
như bây nó đổi tên rồi các bạn. Chờ tí
nhá. Mình xem nó là cái gì. If IDF này
nhá.
Đây mện như nó đổi tên khác rồi. Xem có
cái hàm của nó nhá.
À đâu ấy nhỉ? À bây giờ nó gọi là get
feature name out.
Names out.
Được chưa? Chạy lại nhá.
Phiên bản cũ ngày xưa thì nó chỉ là get
feature name thôi. Mấy cái phiên bản cũ
cũ cũ ngày xưa này. Bây giờ nó đổi tên
khác đi. Được chưa? Chạy lại thử nhá.
lại thử này. Mình thấy là nó chỉ là về
phần giao diện thôi. Đúng sẽ giúp các
bạn nhìn tên nó dễ hơn. Đây này. Các bạn
thấy chưa? Bây giờ hàng nó là tên phim
rồi, còn cột nó là tên của các cái thể
loại rồi. Được chưa? Nhớ là mình có 18
thể loại nữa chưa? Floy là một thể loại
này và Sion là một thể loại khác này.
Được chưa? Như này
đến bước này có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Đến bước này có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì
không?
Nếu các bạn không có câu hỏi thì mình
hỏi các bạn nhá.
Các bạn thấy là cho đến cái bước này
chúng ta đây là chúng ta đã bắt đầu
chúng ta đã tiền xử lý các cái dữ liệu
rồi đúng không? Đây chúng ta đã tiền xử
lý rồi. Các bạn có thấy là ở đây cái
script này của chúng ta so với tất cả
những cái project chúng ta làm trước đây
trong khóa này thì cái project hiện tại
nó đang có một cái điểm bất thường.
Cho đến cái bước này so với các cái
project khác thì ở cái project này nó
đang có một điểm bất thường. Đế bất
tưởng ở đây là gì? Là chúng ta chúng ta
làm sao? Chúng ta chưa có phân chia bộ
train với bộ bộ test đúng không? Chưa
phân chia train va test hay chưa phân
chia train test? Chưa phân chia cái gì
cả. Chúng ta chưa phân chia gì mà chúng
ta đã tiền xử lý rồi đúng không? Chưa
phân chia gì vẫn để nguyên mà đã tiền xử
lý rồi. Lý do là vì sao?
Sao bài này chúng ta chưa phân chia đúng
không? Chưa có chuyên test split gì cả.
Thế nó đã nhảy vào đây luôn rồi. Lý do
là vì sao?
Lý do là vì sao?
Thật ra á
thật ra á thì với học không giám sát hay
là ăn s learning ấy thật ra người ta
muốn người ta vẫn có thể có một cái bộ
validation hoặc có cái bộ test vẫn được.
Thì đơn giản ví dụ các bạn thấy là các
bạn dùng gaming clustering chẳng hạn,
người ta vẫn có thể người ta có một cái
bộ test để xem là để xem là cái mức độ
tương đồng giữa các cái sle trong cùng
một cái cluster là bao nhiêu và và cái
mức độ khác biệt giữa cái sle thuộc các
cái cluster khác nhau nó như thế nào.
Được chưa? Thật ra thì nếu muốn thì vẫn
có thể vẫn có thể chia ra bộ test được.
Thế nhưng mà cái vấn đề ở đây nó là gì?
Vấn đề ở đây nó là bây giờ mình có chia
ra bộ test đi đúng không? Thì ví dụ với
cái bài toán recommendation system này
đúng không? Chúng ta cũng không biết là
bây giờ tôi đánh giá ví dụ bài toán c
min clustering đi. C min cing về mặt bản
chất là gì? Nó phân cụ các cái simple
thành các cái cluster khác nhau. Thì ví
dụ mình có bộ test đi, mình vẫn tuy mình
không có nhãn mình vẫn có thể đ đánh giá
cái sự tương đồng tức là cái khoảng cách
giữa các cái sle trong cùng một cluster
hoặc là khoảng cách giữa sle cho
clustter này đến clustter kia đúng
không? Trong cùng một claster thì càng
gần nhau càng giống nhau càng tốt. Còn
khác claster thì càng cách xác nhau thì
càng tốt thì chúng ta vẫn còn chúng ta
cố vẫn có thể đánh giá được và thật ra
nó vẫn có những cái magic. Thế nhưng mà
bây giờ về cái recom cái recommendation
system này bây giờ muốn đánh giá chúng
ta biết ch biết đánh giá dựa vào cái gì
đúng không? Bây giờ các bạn đưa vào một
cái bộ phim hệ thống nó gợi ý ra 10 top
10 bộ phim đấy. Thì bây giờ đánh giá
kiểu gì bây giờ? Bây giờ hỏi ai đ đá đ
đánh giá bây giờ chạy bây gi lại đi hỏi
đúng cái ông đấy xem là cái ông đấy liệu
là tôi bây giờ tôi gợi ý cho 10 hôm phim
này ông xem phim nào ông ông thích phim
nào à đúng không? Đấy. Thế nên là với
cái recommendation system này thường
người ta sẽ không phân chia ra làm bộ
test. Nếu có nếu có bộ test ấy thì người
ta sẽ cần phải bộ test là sẽ phải cần
phải có đánh nhãn đúng không? Nếu mà
thực sự muốn phân chia bộ test ấ thì bộ
nhá phải có đánh nhãn là gì? Bây tôi
phải yêu cầu có người người ta ngồi
người ta đ đánh nhãn thực sự là ví dụ ví
dụ là các bạn mời cái người ví dụ các
bạn mời chính những cái người mà người
ta là user chẳng hạn đúng không? Các bạn
hỏi xem là bây giờ tôi có một cái list
này anh ngoài cái phim anh vừa xem anh
còn thích cái phim nào nữa được chưa?
Thì bây gi xem cái gợi ý của tôi, tôi có
gợi ý đúng những cái phim đấy không.
Được chưa? Không được các bạn ạ.
Nếu test nếu sao không test bằng cách là
nó có recommend cùng general cùng
general hay không? Không bạn ạ. Tại vì
nếu á nếu bây giờ mà các bạn bảo là đánh
giá cái mức độ tốt của cái dự đoán ấy,
mức độ tổ tốt của gợi ý dựa vào general
ấy thì bây giờ mình chả phải làm gì
nhiều đâu. Bây giờ mình có một người
dùng họ xem cái bộ phim. Bây giờ tôi chỉ
gợi ý cho họ đúng như bộ phim cùng cái
general thế là xong rồi đúng không?
Không dựa vào general không mà đánh giá
được. Tôi dựa vào general để tôi dự để
để để tôi gợi ý cho người dùng thì được
nhưng tôi không dựa vào nó để tôi đánh
giá được. Tại vì bây giờ nếu dự đo đánh
giá thì bây giờ tôi cần gì phải hệ thống
phức tạp đâu. Bây giờ tôi chỉn tôi tìm
xem tất cả những cái phim nào cùng
channel tôi g tôi tôi gợi ý hết thế là
xong đúng không? Ví dụ cái phim người
dùng xem là phim comedy. Bây giờ tôi xem
cái list trong cái trong cái sách sách
này có 200 bộ phim về comedy mình gợi ý
cho hết tên là xong. Tức là điểm 100%
ngay đúng không? Đấy nó không dễ như vậy
đúng không?
Rồi. Ok. Có bắt nào câu hỏi nữa không?
Tiếp nhá.
Tiếp nhá. Thế thế bây giờ chúng ta xử lý
xong rồi đúng không? Bây giờ các bạn có
một cái a
bây giờ các bạn có một cái magic mình
mình gọi là một cái dance magic như này
nhá. Vẫn nhớ nhá. Nhiệm vụ ra là gì? Là
bây giờ người dùng họ xem cái bộ phim
nào đấy tôi phải gửi ý cho họ top 20 top
30 bộ phim mà tương đồng nhất với bộ
phim đó. thôi. Và tôi chú ý là tôi dựa
tương đồng tôi dựa vào cái general của
thôi được chưa? Magic này rồi.
Thế bây giờ theo các bạn bây giờ tôi có
cái magic này rồi.
Đây mỗi một cái bộ phim tôi đã số hóa nó
thành một cái vecơ có độ dài là 18 phần
tử. Tức độ dài cố định đấy. Đúng không?
Thế bây giờ tôi muốn đánh giá sự tương
đồng giữa hai bộ phim mà cụ thể tôi đánh
giá sự tương đồng giữa hai vecơ. Tôi làm
cái gì bây giờ?
Tôi làm cái gì bây giờ?
Làm gì bây giờ?
À đúng rồi. Tính C đúng rồi. Tính City.
Chính xác. Chính xác.
Đúng rồi. Thế bây giờ cách cái cách dễ
nhất mà tôi có thể nghĩ ra là gì? Là bây
giờ nhá trong tương lai nhá người dùng
họ xem cái bộ phim nào đấy ở đây đúng
không? Ví dụ họ xem bộ phim là Golden
Eyes năm 1995 này. Được chưa? xem này.
Rồi thì bây giờ tôi muốn bây giờ tôi
muốn gửi ý cho họ tôi sẽ làm nào? Tôi sẽ
tính cái cosity giữa cái bộ phim này và
gần 4000 bộ phim còn lại được không? Tôi
tính cái cos giữa cái vecơ của bộ phim
này với gần 4000 vecơ còn lại thì tôi
xem là
tôi xem là cái điểm nó như nào và tôi sẽ
trả lại về top 10 cái bộ phim mà có cái
vecơ có cái c bấm này nó lớn nhất. Tức
là người dùng họ cứ xem một bộ phim nào
tôi sẽ tính câu sa của tất cả bộ phim
còn lại với cái bộ phim đó. Được chưa?
Rồi tôi tô tìm ra cái top. Cách tiếp cận
này thì có nhược điểm gì? Cái cách mà
bây giờ người dùng cứ họ cứ xem như nào?
Tôi bắt đầu tôi tôi tính thì cô sai x
của cho bộ nói nó có nhược điểm gì đây?
Nhược điểm gì?
điểm gì? Bây giờ người dùng họ cứ xem
cái bộ phim mà tôi bắt đầu tôi sẽ tôi sẽ
ngồi tôi lục tính cái câu sap của bộ
phim đó với tất cả những bộ phim còn
lại. Tìm top 10 đúng mỗi lần c ý chương
trình hình lại phải chạy một lần có
nghĩa là nó sẽ làm sao? Mỗi lần c ý phải
chạy lại một lần có nghĩa là nó sẽ ừ
đúng rồi. Độ phức tạp là cái phương đúng
không? Nó lâu lâu quá đúng không? chạy
nó lâu quá đúng cứ mỗi bây giờ mà đây
các bạn thấy hiểu sao này hết tôm nay nó
quen nó chỉ phục vụ một người đâu nó
phục vụ rất nhiều người đúng không cả
chục người họ cùng accept một lần đúng
không làm thế nó lâu lắm
bây giờ làm thế nào bây giờ lâu thế làm
nào bây giờ
lâu thế làm nào bây giờ
đúng rồi tính trước đính trước có nghĩa
là gì tính trước có nghĩa là bây giờ
chúng ta sẽ làm cái gì đúng phải tính
trước không phải chờ đến đời nữa mà phải
tính trước tính trước là tôi sẽ làm Cái
gì?
Tính trước là tôi sẽ làm cái gì?
Lập ma trận simt lập như nào? Lập ma
trận này dựa trên input là cái gì đây?
Chính xác. Tức là bây giờ bây giờ tôi sẽ
tính cái cos simity của 4000 bộ phím này
với.
Bây giờ tôi tính câ s của 4 bộ phim này
với cái gì?
Tôi sẽ tính câu sai symmetry của 4000 bộ
phim này với cái gì? Của gần 4000 bộ
phim này với cái gì?
Với chính nó. Chính xác. Với chính nó
đúng không? Đây mình có gần 4000 bộ phim
mình sẽ tính với chính nó luôn. Được
chưa? Tính cos tất nhiên là các bạn sẽ
được một cái vecơ các bạn sẽ được một
cái ma trận vuông đường ché chánh luôn
bằng 1 rồi tại vì là câu sa của một bộ
phim 19 nó luôn bằng 1 đúng không thì
tôi sẽ dựa tôi sẽ có cái ma trận này ma
trận vuông này sau này tôi tìm tôi sẽ
chỉ lấy đúng cái hàng lấy cô từng thôi
được chưa
rồi nào thế bây giờ tôi muốn tính câu si
city thì ra có rất nhiều cách khác nhau
trong 5 nó cũng có trong trong pandas nó
cũng có và tự như trong seit learn thì
nó cũng nó cũng có luôn các bạn nhìn nhá
Nhiều lắm 5 P cũng có panas có si l có
ví dụ nhá cái nhá se này cze sim nhá
này được chưa ờ form đúng không
formmatmri.pspwise
được chưa import city này cái này dùng
rất là dễ thôi. Một là các bạn đưa hai
cái bộ các bạn đưa hai cái mảng x y vào
thì nó sẽ tính cosity giữa từng cái phần
tử từng cái vecơ của x và từng vectơ của
y. Còn nếu mà các bạn chỉ đưa mỗi x thôi
ấy mà các bạn không đưa y vào thì nó sẽ
coi như là cái này này đúng không? Nếu y
mà là non này thì cái output sẽ là cái
câu suy của x với cả chính nó luôn. Đấy
chính là cái mình cần đấy. Chính là cái
mình cần. Mình muốn tính câu sai series
của x với chính nó luôn. Được chưa? Nhìn
đây nhá.
Nhìn nhá.
In cpt này được chưa? Thế dưới bên đâu
mình sẽ bây giờ mình mình tính thôi. Đây
dưới này nhá. Được chưa? Dưới này cho
dưới này đi mình sẽ gọi là gì nhở? C này
không bằng câu này. Đấy mình sẽ tính
trên cái tính trên cái ma trận này. Được
chưa?
ma trận mà trước khi chúng ta đưa về
dạng dance ấy. Được chưa? Câu ST này thì
mình sẽ bây giờ mình sẽ
chạy thử nhá. Chạy thử xem nó ra cái gì.
Hình như là cũng chưa xem ngay nữa đâu.
Đây thế này nó nó là một cái ma trận gì
các bạn? Ma trận này đường chéo chính
thì luôn bằng 1 đúng không? Và các phần
tử không phải đường chéo chính nó đối
xứng nhau qua đường nhó chính này. Đây
là một cái ma trận đối xứng đúng không?
Ma trận đối xứng các bạn có thể dựa vào
nửa trên cũng được. Các bạn sẽ ở nửa
dưới cũng ok đúng không? Nhận đối xứng
này được chưa? Nó có gần 4000 hàng và nó
có gần 4000 cột được chưa? Hà 4000 và
cột cũng 4000. Được chưa?
Rồi
thì bây giờ chúng ta có cái ma trận này
rồi đúng không? Thì có phải là bây giờ
các bạn có cái ma trận này rồi sau này
các bạn à có một cái bộ phim vào đây.
Các bạn chỉ cần lấy đúng cái hàng hoặc
cái cột tứng của nó là thôi đúng không?
Ví dụ các các bạn có cái bộ phim số 10,
các bạn bê nguyên cái hàng số 10 rồi các
bạn tìm tiếp rồi các bạn sắp xếp hoặc là
các bạn bê nguyên cái cột số 10 các bạn
sắp xếp là xong. Được chưa? Thế nhưng mà
bây giờ để sử dụng cái bảng này cho nó
dễ ấ thì chúng ta phải làm giống như vừa
rồi tức là gì? Bây giờ tên hàng và tên
cột ấy nó đều là số 0 1 2 3 4 này nhìn
rất là khó. Bây giờ bây giờ mình cứ phải
ngồi cứ đảo mắt qua đảo mắt lại xem là
cái số 0 là phim gì, phim 1 nó là phim
gì đúng không? Thì bây già cái tên cột
này mình sẽ không dùng cái con số này
nữa. Mình sẽ lại dùng title được chưa?
Tôi lại dùng cái title để tôi đặt tên
hàng và đặt tên cột này được chưa? Giống
như ở trên này. Trên này được chưa? Trên
này này.
Ciz này. Team này df ta được chưa? Bằng
pandas này. Được chưa? Pandas này cái
tên của hàng cũng là title mà tên của hồ
cột thì cũng là title luôn. Được chưa?
Đây ta
th này được chưa? Cả hàng cột đều thay
thôn. Thì các bạn sẽ nhìn bây giờ các
bạn thấy là tôi sẽ muốn biết là bộ phim
nào tư tương tổng phi nào rất là dễ.
Đây chưa? Sau này người dùng mà họ xem
cái phim Nixon thì các bạn lấy nguyên
cái hàng của ông Nixon này hoặc các bạn
lấy cái cột của ông Nixon nó xem hàng
hoặc xem cột đều ok cả. Được chưa? Nxon
nằm chỗ nào?
Đâu ấy nhỉ? Này NX này được chưa? Lấy
hàng của Non lấy cột của NXON đều được.
Được chưa? Thế thì có vẻ đến đây rồi
đúng không? Đến đây rồi. Chúng ta có cái
ma trận này rồi. Thì bây giờ giả sử b
người dùng sau này họ xem một cái bộ
phim gì nhá. Ví dụ họ xem bộ phim là
phim gì bây giờ nhở? Phim nào mình sẽ có
nhiều thể loại tí. Ví dụ mình lấy luôn
cái phim a
phim đầu phim đầu tiên đi. Mình thấy
phim đầu tiên có nhiều thể loại đấy. Đây
này.
Tome story nhá. Được chưa? để luôn cái
phim này đi. Còn ví dụ là người dùng họ
xem cái phim gọi là
ơ movie à không là ờ
movie
và như này được chưa? Thì bây giờ có vẻ
là bây giờ mình sẽ phải tìm được top 20
bộ phim hoặc là top 30 đi. Ví dụ mình
ghi là top K. Top K bằng 20. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ mình sẽ lấy ra nguyên cái
hàng của cái ông này hoặc lấy nguyên cột
ông này là xong gì đúng không? Bây giờ
mình lấy thử nhá. Ví dụ là
movie
bằng cái gì? Bằng bằng cái
bằng cái câu si này. Được chưa? Mình sẽ
lấy tại vì bây giờ các bạn thấy là bây
giờ các bạn thấy là bây giờ cái với cái
ma trận này nhá. Tên của hàng và tên cột
đ tên phim nên bây gi các bạn muốn lấy
cái hàng này chẳng hạn bình thường các
bạn phải lấy chỉ số là chỉ số 2 đúng
không? 0 1 2 bình thường các bạn lấy chỉ
số 2 các bạn phải lấy cái tên là chỉ số
của nó. Bây gi các bạn thể lấy dùng tên
của nó để các bạn lấy lấy luôn được
chưa? Ví dụ đây đâu rồi?
Chết rồi lại lỡ đây. Xóa rồi
đây. Được chưa?
Bây giờ mình sẽ
mình sẽ lấy cái sim movie đây
như này mình sẽ in ra.
Tất nhiên đây theo đây cũng chưa phải
top đâu. Đây chỉ là cái lấy nguyên cái
hàng này thôi. Lấy nguyên cái hàng này
thôi. Top movie nhá.
Tôi in ra cái hàng nó còn nhiều lắm đúng
không? Nó mình sẽ in ra đây là nó lấy
hết này đúng không? Chạy lại nhá.
Ờ chốt movie nhá. Ch m đây. Thực ra này
là mình đ mình đang lấy nguyên cái hàng
đúng không? Mình l mình lấy hàng đấy chứ
không phải mình lấy cột đâu. Chẳng qua
lấy hàng xong bây giờ nó v nó nó show ra
nó show thành cột này thôi. Các bạn lấy
nguyên cái hàng của nó. nguyên cái hàng
của cái phim Toy Story tất nhiên là sẽ
bùng cả cả chính nó nữa. Tại vì là tại
vì là mình đang lấy cái ma trận City
giữa một cái phim với với cả chính nó
mà. Được chưa? Đấy.
Thế thì bây giờ mình sẽ bây giờ mình sẽ
phải làm gì tiếp các bạn? Bây giờ có
rồi, bây giờ phải làm cái gì tiếp? Bây
giờ mình muốn lấy ra top 20, top 30 mình
phải làm gì bây giờ? Làm gì bây giờ?
Muốn lấy top 20, top 30 mình phải làm
cái gì bây giờ?
Phile short. Đúng rồi. Phải short đã
phải sắp xếp đúng không? Sắp xếp chết
rồi. Lại lỡ
s lại lỡ tay tắt đi rồi chờ một tí nhá.
Đây được chưa? Bây giờ mình sẽ phải sắp
xếp. Sắp xếp thì có nhiều cách lắm. Thật
ra là ngay trong pandas ấy nó đã có một
cái hàm hàm là là đã có ngay một cái hàm
gọi là hàm hàm sắp xếp rồi. Đây nó có
một cái hàm short này.
Value này. Được chưa?
H ơ sao đăng này nó chạy này
value được chưa các bạn sẽ có một cái
nữa là accending
sending bằng vol
tại vì
accent là tăng descend là giảm đúng chưa
accent là tăng des giảm và các bạn có
thể các bạn sẽ lấy a
đây lấy cứ chạy này đã nhá cứ chạy xem
nó sắp xếp như Nào nhá.
Top movie nhá. Này nó sắp hết rồi này.
Mấy mấy cái ông cứ một chạy lên hết lên
trên đầu này. Được chưa? Đấy m ông dưới
0,9 mấy cái thứ này. Được chưa? F này
bây giờ mình mới lấy top bao nhiêu? Mình
mới lấy top 20.
Top 20 thì các bạn dùng slicing này thôi
cũng được. Top này. Tất nhiên các bạn
phải các bạn sẽ phải lọc thêm chính cái
bộ phim đấy đi nữa. Được chưa? Đ lại
nhá.
Đây top 20 được chưa?
1 này nhắn được chưa? Tất nhiên nó sẽ
dính ở chính cái bộ phim này nữa. Toy
Story đúng không? Tại vì chính cái bộ
phim này nó cũng là cái ông có c vòng 1
mà thì mình sẽ phải lọc nó đi đúng
không? Mình có thể lọc mình dựa vào cái
tên. Một là các bạn lọc từ đây. Hai là
gì? Hai là lúc mà các bạn Hai là lúc mà
các bạn tạo ra cái ma trận này này. Các
bạn đổi cái đường chéo chính các bạn cho
thành -1 hết là xong. -1 nó là bé nhất
rồi. Nó bé hơn cả 0 không bao giờ nó đưa
chọn cả. Có nhiều cách được chưa? Đây là
cách để các bạn có thể xây dựng cái
recommendation system chỉ dựa vào nội
dung thôi. Lọc nội dung đấy. Được chưa?
Dựa vào đúng cái nội dung thôi chưa phải
quan tâm đến cái tương tác của những cái
user khác. Tôi chỉ quan tâm đến tôi
thôi. Được chưa?
Muốn có top lớn hơn thì nãy các bạn đổi
đổi đổi thử phím khác đi. Đổi phím khác
ví dụ các bạn có cái phim đây hết 1995
đây. V action đúng không? Thể loại phim
hành động tội phạm với cả dùng rợn giật
gân đúng không?
Đây
khác nhá.
T một vi đây đ không cũng là loại tội
phạm dùng giận gần này hacker được chưa?
Han to watch over me đúng không? Nhìn
cái tên nghe trọng có vẻ đấy rồi đúng
corrupt corrupter đúng không? Tên phím
biết có thiếu gì không? Giờ chờ giờ chết
thế thôi.
Có bác nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào có câu hỏi? Có bạn có thắc
mắc gì không?
Chúng ta nghỉ giá 5 phút các bạn nhá.
Nghỉ giá 5 phút nhá.
Chúng ta sẽ còn nửa buổi hôm nay, một
buổi ngày mai và nửa buổi thứ bảy tuần
sau nữa. Lớp chúng ta học ra là học
nhanh học nhanh hơn so rồi các cái lớp
khác. Các lớp khác thì thường là xong
cái này là là còn nửa buổi là mình chỉ
giới thiệu về các cái tổng kết các thứ
thôi. Nhưng mà lớp mình học xong còn hai
buổi chúng ta sẽ đưa một vài cái nội
dung khác vào nhá.
Ai có th gì bạn cứ hỏi nhá. Mình sẽ đọc
báo một tí này.
Ừ cũng có mà các bạn có cái phần liên
quan đến a
phần liên quan đến model liên quan đến
NLP tại vì khóa đấy gốc là về NLP mà
được chưa? Thì nó là cái phần liên quan
đến NLP. Ờ
ừ chú là cái phần liên quan đến NLP
thôi. Cái khóa đấy thì à
ừ cái khóa đấy mình nghĩ là về mặt kiến
thức nó sẽ
nó sẽ nặng hơn khóa này. Nó sẽ nặng hơn
tại vì nó sẽ nặng hơn cái phần liên quan
đến kiến trúc của Transformer. Các bạn
chú ý nhá. Đấy vẫn là khóa phải code đấy
nhá. Đấy không phải khóa đấy các bạn kéo
thả nhá. Vẫn phải code nhá. code nên là
nó cũng không khó lắm đâu nhưng mà
anyway vẫn phải code nhá. Tất cả các
khóa của mình không ít thì nhiều trừ có
lẽ chửi khóa toán ra thì khóa nào cũng
phải code cả.
Code nó nó mệt đầu hơn kéo thả nhưng mà
code thì các bạn sẽ có cái tính tùy
chỉnh cao hơn. Một phần trong đấy một
phần đấy là VM một phần trong đấy là
Vision language model.
Nhưng nó phần nhỏ thôi. Khóa đấy vẫn là
khóa thiên về NP hơn. Nào các bạn thích
computer mission các bạn sang khóa
linking for computer vision ấ thì nó chỉ
có computer vision thôi.
>> [khịt mũi]
>> No
f to có mấy ai người ta file tun đâu
không phải không phải các bạn hôm nọ các
bạn nhìn thấy Viettel đúng không chị
Viettel ông lớn rất là lớn rồi th nó khó
lắm thường người ta sử dụ thay vì người
ta file thun ta sẽ dùng ra r nó sẽ tiện
hơn và nó sẽ phù hợp hơn với kiểu là cái
rượu nó cập nhật liên tục và bây giờ các
cái mô hình mới nó ra liên tục các bạn
file tun xong một cái mô hình ra ngoài
các bạn thấy là có những cái mô hình
khác nó tốt hơn rồi đúng không phải thun
tốn thời gian lắm vừa tốn thời gian vừa
tốn giữ Dữ liệu rá nhanh hơn nhiều.
Cái này là ở Stanford. Ừ. Đấy mới ngay
cái kiểu bản này của Stanford.
AI agent R chatpot được chưa? Và kiểu
multiagent gọi làic AI đấy chưa?
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Nhưng khóa về lý thuyết nó sẽ khó hơn
khóa này đấy nhá. Lý thuyết nó sẽ khó
hơn khóa này đấy nhá.
Mình sẽ code bằng line trên mà. Mình sẽ
c bằng lan trên mà. Chúng ta sẽ code
bằng lan trên.
Thật ra công tâm mà nói thì bây giờ
chúng ta có những cái framework khác nó
tốt hơn lang trên xong rồi sử dụng
chatpot hoặc là agent ví dụ như là L
grap hoặc là lama index của meta đúng
không? Nhưng mà lang trên nó vẫn dễ tiếp
cận hơn vẫn dễ tiếp cận hơn và mình nghĩ
là nó vẫn sẽ phù hợp hơn khi chúng ta
mới mới làm quen mới bắt đầu.
Rồi
ra xong rồi. Thế bây giờ mình đang có
một vài những cái topic mà tại vì như
vậy mình nói cái khoán lớp này chúng ta
chúng ta kết thúc sớm hơn so với các cái
lớp trước nên mình muốn cho một vài cái
topic khác. Mình có thể một là bây giờ
mình có một mình có hai option này cho
các bạn nhá. có hai option này.
Option đầu tiên là chúng ta sẽ học về
Docker
và option thứ hai là chúng ta sẽ đó
chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu chúng ta sẽ nói qua
một chút về
chúng ta sẽ nói qua một chút về
deing for computer vision. Được chưa? Có
hai cái chủ đề vậy. Một là docker hay là
deing for computeration. Đầu tiên mình
muốn hỏi lớp mình một chút này. Lớp mình
có bạn nào các bạn biết cách sử dụng
docker? Các bạn cho mình số 1, còn bạn
nào các bạn không biết cách sử dụng cho
mình số 0.
Ồ
không ai từng sụ nó cơ. Ok hay quá nhỉ.
À git nhá. Git là gì? Các bạn tưởng
tượng này hiện nay ấy trong cái khóa này
ừ hiện nay trong cái a trong cái khóa
này chúng ta đang code độc lập đúng
không? Tất cả chúng ta đều là
code một mình đúng không? Mình code một
mình mình không có hợp tác với ai, mình
không có cooperate với ai cả. Các bạn
cũng thế. Thì nếu chúng ta code mình thì
không sao. Nhưng các bạn tưởng tượng bây
giờ giả sử bây gi các bạn bắt đầu có hai
người cùng nhau code đi. Hai người cùng
nhau code thì lúc này nó sẽ có một cái
vấn đề đó là gì? Bây giờ cùng cái file
đấy, cùng một cái script đấy. Bây giờ
hai ông cùng code ví dụ ông a ông đấy có
một cái thay đổi gì đấy mà ông đấy mà
chỉ lưu chức ở máy cục bộ thôi thì ông B
ông đấy sẽ không biết đúng không? Cùng
cái project đấy hai ông cùng code trong
cùng cái script. Thì bây giờ ông này
thay đổi cái gì ông kia sẽ không biết
đúng không? Lúc đấy cái vai trò của Wi
nó sẽ thể được thể hiện là gì? Đây là
cái nơi để chúng ta có thể chúng ta đẩy
chúng ta đồng bộ hóa code giữa các
developer đúng không? Để đảm bảo là gì?
Đảm bảo bây giờ là 5 hay là 10 người
cùng code trong cùng một cái project thì
chúng ta vẫn luôn luôn đảm bảo là code
chúng ta sẽ được đồng bộ. Người này có
cái update gì thì người kia cũng sẽ được
biết. Không không phải không phải Drop.
Dropot nó nó chỉ chia sẻ file thôi mà.
Dropbox nó chỉ dùng để chia sẻ file
thôi. Nó chả khác gì trên Google Drive
cả. Các bạn up cái file lên Google Drive
hoặc các bạn up trên Google Dropbox hoặc
là các bạn up trên mạng. trên media file
ngày xưa đúng không? Thì nó chỉ là nơi
để các bạn chia sẻ file thôi. Đây không
phải ví dụ các bạn có ba người, ba ông
cùng code trên cùng một cái script chẳng
hạn đúng không? Thế bây giờ tôi có thể
đồng bộ tức là gì? Cứ ông này có thay
đổi gì thì ông kia cũng sẽ có nhả có thể
có những cái update tương ứng đúng
không? Để làm sao nó phù hợp đảm bảo là
ba ông cùng làm trên cùng cái script nó
tương đương nhau đúng không? Đấy là
nhiệm vụ của git. Thế nhưng mà git thì
phải khi nào các bạn đi làm ở công ty
các bạn mà làm trong những cái team bắt
đầu nhiều người người ta cùng code ấy
trong cùng một project ấy thì lúc ấy các
bạn sẽ sẽ cần sụp đến git.
Ờ git thì thật ra nó không quá khó nhưng
mà nó phải có cái môi trường thực hành.
Còn các bạn học tranh nó sẽ hơi khó một
chút. Đấy git các bạn tưởng tượng là
công cụ để làm sao giúp cho các lập
trình viên có thể làm việc cùng trong
cùng một team mà không bị rối nhau,
không bị giẫm chất lên nhau. Được chưa?
Không sẽ không có. Người ta sẽ có cái cơ
chế để làm sao để tránh trồng lần như
vậy. Tức là khi mà các bạn code các bạn
sẽ push cái code của bạn lên. Push tức
là đẩy. Đấy đẩy đẩy code lên. Đẩy code
lên. Được chưa? đẩy code lên để làm sao
để những người khác người ta có thể nhận
biết được cái sự thay đổi đấy và người
ta sẽ full cái code mới về. Được chưa?
Các bạn có một cái update gì mới các bạn
kiểm tra được là cái update này nó ok
rồi. Nó không gây nó không gây ra hỏng
hóc gì cho cái hệ thống. Các bạn sẽ các
bạn sẽ bắt đầu các bạn push lên push lên
người khác người ta sẽ người ta nếu mà
người ta làm cùng trên cùng một cái là
cùng trên cái branch cùng các bạn ấy ta
sẽ bắt đầu người ta sẽ phải full là kéo
về đấy. Kéo về lấy về được chưa?
ta sẽ cái project trên thực tế người ta
sẽ có một cái một cái nhánh một một cái
một người ta gọi là một cái nhánh chính
một cái band chính tức là các bạn tưởng
tượng như một cái project ghup đấy nhá
đây này
cái project trên ghép này nhá
đây là cái project mình làm cho cho
trường kinh tế quốc dân con ch boss như
này bao giờ một project nó bao giờ nó nó
cũng có một cái main branch hoặc là
nhiều khi người ta sẽ gọi nó là master
branch
Được chưa? Đây cái nhánh chính.
Từ nhánh chính này sẽ tạo ra rất nhiều
những cái nhánh con giống ở một cái cây
ấ có một cái thân nhánh chính có nhiều
nhánh nhánh con đấy thì nh những cái
nhánh con này sẽ là những cái lập trình
viên họ thêm cái feature gì đấy ví dụ
các bạn có cái trang web đi ông này ông
lấy thêm một cái nút ông kia ông lấy
thêm một cái size bar ông n thêm một cái
progress bar kiểu kiểu như vậy thì mỗi
một ông khi muốn thêm cái đặc thêm một
cái feature đấy vào họ sẽ tạo ra một cái
branch cái nhánh con họ sẽ làm việc trên
cái nhánh này khi nào mà ngọn họ code gì
là họ sẽ đẩy lên cái nhánh này họ sẽ p
nhánh này và khi nào mà nó ok người khác
cũng có thể người ta sẽ người khác mà
cùng làm trên cái nhánh này người ta sẽ
pull về để lấy được những cái update mới
nhất.
Code xong xuôi hết rồi thì người ta bắt
đầu người ta sẽ merge nó, tức là người
ta sẽ gộp nó lại về cái nhánh chính để
cái nhánh chính nó sẽ có những cái
update này. Đấy nhưng cái này thì khi mà
các bạn đi làm các bạn sẽ nó sẽ dễ còn
các bạn lựa chay nó sẽ hơi khó. Lượn
chay nó khó có cái để hình dung được
chưa? Ít ra nó không khó. Nó chỉ có cái
môi trường thực hành môi trường qu luyện
tập thôi là ok rồi. Được chưa?
Đấy nó phải docker đi. Docker.
Ok. Thế bây giờ các bạn đây các bạn đều
chưa nghe docker bao giờ. Ok.
Bạn chưa dùng bao giờ? Mình hỏi một cái
này. Lớp mình có bạn nào các bạn đã từng
được học qua cái môn gọi là môn lập
trình hướng đối tượng rồi. Lập trình
hướng đối tượng thì các bạn cho mình số
1. Các bạn nào mà các bạn chưa từng học
cái môn lập trình đối tượng này các bạn
cho mình số 0. Object orient
programming. Đấy.
Rồi các bạn nhìn nhá. Rồi ok. Thì bây
giờ ấy muốn dễ hiểu doer chúng ta sẽ
phải nói về lập trình của đối tượng.
Các bạn tưởng tượng này, ngày xưa hồi
phổ thông đi, cái hồi phổ thông lớp 10,
lớp 11, lớp 12 ấ các bạn có cái môn tin
học đúng không? Các bạn nhớ cái hồi các
bạn học môn tin học đấy, các bạn học
ngôn ngữ gì các bạn? Thường ngày xưa
mình phải học Pascal nhưng mà hình như
bây giờ các bạn các bạn trẻ bây giờ có
nhiều option thì các bạn có này, các bạn
có Python này,
có cả mab à cấp ba học cả. Ok.
Cái thời ngày xưa của mình học Pascal
cái ngôn ngữ này bây giờ nó chả có ai
dùng nữa các bạn ạ. Pascal thì bây giờ
chả có ai dùng nữa. Nó quá là cổ rồi
đấy. Ngày xưa mình dùng passkan hình như
bây giờ có những bạn đều học Python, có
những bạn đ học C. Thế thì các bạn nhìn
này. Các bạn nhìn nhá.
cái kiểu lập trình của PASCAN ấy
hoặc là cái kiểu lập trình của chúng ta
là đầu đến giờ cả cái khóa này cả cái
khóa này cái kiểu lập trình của chúng ta
là kiểu lập trình truyền thống nó tuyến
tính nó tuyến tính chạy từ trên xuống
dưới. Tức là gì? Dòng nào cos trước thì
chạy trước, dòng nào cos sau thì chạy
sau. Thì đây được gọi là kiểu lập trình
tuyến tính.
Và kiểu lập trình này là cái kiểu lập
trình mà chúng ta học suốt những năm
tháng học phổ thông ấy mà cả những năm
và cả cái năm chúng ta học đại cương
chúng ta học môn những môn kiểu cơ sở
lập trình ấy cái kiểu lập trình này
người ta gọi là lập trình hướng cấu trúc
lập trình hướng cấu trúc lập trình hướng
cấu trúc hoặc là các bạn mà dùng những
cái các bạn mà code trên kiểu Jupiter
Notebook ấy thì chính xác đấy là chính
là hầu hết là nó sẽ là kiểu lập trình
hướng cấu trúc ông nào code trên chạy
trên chạy trước ông là code dưới chạy
sau
lập trường à lập trình hướng cấu trúc
thì nó có một cái ưu điểm là nó dễ tiếp
cận và dễ cho người mới học người ta
hình dung. Nhưng mà điều nhược điểm là
gì? Nhược điểm của lập trình hướng cấu
trúc ấy là gì? Là do là nó chạy cái kiểu
tuyến tính như vậy. Thế nên ấy là nếu mà
có một cái chỗ này nó có lỗi. Ví dụ đi.
Ví dụ ngày xưa mình nhớ là cái hồi mình
học ở Bách Khoa có một cái môn gọi là
môn kỹ thuật lập trình. Đấy mình code
cái bài tập lớn là code 2000 dòng ở đây
chưa có chat TV các bạn nhá. Chưa có
chat TV. Code là code thủ công luôn á.
2000 dòng code thủ công luôn.
Cái bài tập là cây đạo hàng cây cây nhị
phân tính đạo hàng. Như vậy các bạn
tưởng tượng nhá bây giờ code 2000 dầm
như vậy. Bây giờ chẳng may ở dòng số
1000 sau khi mình code xong hết rồi, ở
dòng số 1000 mình phát hiện ra là mình
mắc một cái lỗi. Được chưa? Ở dòng số
1000 mình phát hiện ra là mình mắc một
cái lỗi.
Thế bây giờ nếu mình sửa ở cái dòng 1000
này thì những cái dòng phía trên nó nó
chả bị làm sao chả ảnh hưởng gì cả.
Những cái dòng từ dòng số 0 là dòng số 1
đến dòng ch9 chả ảnh hưởng gì. Nhưng từ
dòng số 1000 này đến những cái dòng sau
nó sẽ bị ảnh hưởng. Được chưa? Nó sẽ bị
ảnh hưởng. Mình sẽ phải mửa lại.
Đấy là nh cái nhược điểm của chính hướng
cấu trúc.
Thế bây gi các bạn tưởng tượng sao các
bạn đi làm ở công ty code nó có thể đến
hàng nghìn à hàng triệu dòng thế bây giờ
code xong bây giờ cứ sửa chỗ đấy là phải
đi ngồi sửa tất cả những dòng sau đấy
thì có màt chết đúng không? Do đó thì
trong thực tế trong môi trường làm việc
thực tế sẽ chẳng ai người ta lập trình
theo kiểu lập trình hướng cấu trúc như
vậy. Người ta sẽ phải đổi sang một cái
thể loại mới người ta gọi là lập trình
hướng đối tượng đúng không? Object
orient programming. Bạn nào các bạn là
sợ dịch dân IT thì chắc chắn các bạn
không thể không biết đến cái môn học này
đúng không? Lập trình hối tượng thường
thì khi các bạn học về lập trình đối
tượng ấ các bạn sẽ học ngôn ngữ giống
như kiểu là C+ C+ hoặc là Java đúng
không? Python thì nó cũng có lập trình
hướng ấn tượng nhưng mà Python thì chưa
bao giờ nổi tiếng và chưa bao giờ mạnh
về lập trình hướng đối tượng cả. Lập
trình hướng đối tượng nó sẽ hơi bị phức
tạp một chút trong khi Python thì nó
hướng đến cái sự đơn giản tối ưu. Bạn
nào các bạn từng học cái môn này các bạn
học về Cộng với Java bạn thấy là nó rất
là khó đúng không? H tượng có nhiều thứ
khó lắm khai báo này khai báo kia rất
nhiều thứ khó mà Python lại hướng đến
cái sự đơn giản.
thể nó cũng có lập trình hướng đối tượng
nhưng mà nó đã tinh giản bớt nhiều thứ
rồi.
Đế thì các bạn tưởng tượng này. Bây giờ
nói về trong lập trình hướng đối tượng.
Trong lập trình hướng đối tượng ấy thì
người ta sẽ có hai cái khái niệm rất là
quan trọng
là lớp và đối tượng nhá. Lớp và đối
tượng.
Đầu tiên mình sẽ nói về lớp trước hay là
class
gì?
Lớp là biết bút vẽ nó còn vẽ được không?
Chờ mình một chút nhá. Bút đâu nhỉ?
Mất cái bút rồi.
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Chúng ta sẽ có hai
khái niệm. nó là
class tất cả
năm chức xem cái hình minh họa nó dễ
nhìn không
đây rồi
đây các bạn nhìn nhá
trong lộ trường đối tượng ấy không cái
này nó cũng không hình này nó không nó
không nó không không rõ lắm không cái
này được. Ờ
đây các bạn nhìn nhá.
Trong a
ờ
trong lập trình hướng tượng các bạn sẽ
có hai cái khái niệm đó là
ơ các bạn chờ tí mình đây mình có slide
này mình mở mở slide của lớp Python chờ
mình một tí nhá. Mình sẽ slide khác nhìn
nó dễ hơn.
Pon đâu nhở?
Chơ mình một xíu nha. À đây rồi đây rồi
nhá.
Đây như thế này.
Đây các bạn nhìn nhá. M tạm slide của
Python cơ bản. Các bạn nhìn này. Class
về object nó là cái gì? Class các bạn
tưởng tượng nó chính là một cái bản vẽ,
một cái bản thiết kế của một cái loại
của một cái loại à của một cái loại đối
tượng nào đấy. Được chưa? Nó là một cái
một cái bản vẽ, một cái bản thiết kế. Ví
dụ cái class xe ô tô thì đấy chính là
cái bản thiết kế của một cái xe ô tô.
Bản thiết kế tức là gì? Tức là tôi muốn
tạo ra một cái xe ô tô sau này thì tôi
sẽ phải tuân theo cái bản thiết kế này.
Được chưa? Thế thì trong cái bản thiết
kế này các bạn sẽ phải định nghĩa cái
gì? Trong cái bản thiết kế này các bạn
sẽ đẽ phải thể định nghĩa xem là một cái
xe ô tô thì nó có những cái đặc điểm gì
và nó có thể làm được những cái gì. Được
chưa? một cái xe ô tô nó sẽ có đặc điểm
gì và nó có thể làm được những cái gì?
Đặc điểm trong cái bản thiết kế này ấ
thì những cái đặc điểm mà các bạn muốn
chỉ ra của một cái xe ô tô thực tế thì
nó sẽ gọi là những cái attribute, những
cái thuộc tính đúng không? Attribute là
thuộc tính tức là sau này một cái đối
tượng được tạo ra ấy của cái class này
nó phải có cái thu tính đó. Được chưa?
Ví dụ xe ô tô các bạn sẽ có những cái
thu tính gì? Các bạn sẽ có những thu
tính như là bánh xe, vô lăng, ương chiếu
hậu, ngày sản xuất, hãng xe, giá tiền,
dùng loại xăng gì đúng không? Đây là
những cái thuộc tính của một cái xe. Thế
còn những ngoài những cái thuộc tính mà
một cái xe nó có thì chúng ta sẽ phải
định nghĩa cả những ngoài việc định
nghĩa cái thu tính một cái xe có thì
chúng ta phải định nghĩa cả những cái
hành vi mà một cái xe nó có thể làm.
Hành vi ở đây có nghĩa là gì? là một cái
xe nó có thể đi thẳng, nó có thể đi lùi,
nó có thể rẽ trái, nó có thể rẽ phải, nó
có thể xi nhan, nó có thể bóp coi đúng
không? Đấy thì đây là cái khái niệm về
class. Class nó chính là một cái bản
thiết kế của một cái loại đối tượng gì
đấy. Ví dụ vừa rồi là cái ví dụ là về
cái class là
xe ô tô thì bây giờ các bạn có một cái
class là person nó cũng thế thôi. Cái
class person này các bạn phải đính xem
là một người thì họ có những cái đặc
điểm gì. Và họ có những hành vi gì? Ví
dụ mọi người có những cái đặc điểm là
tên, ngày tháng năm sinh, nơi sinh, quấy
quán, màu da đúng không? Chiều cao, cân
nặng, giới tính đúng không? Thế cái
thông tin về một người nó chính là những
thuộc tính đúng không? Sau này bất kể
một cái người nào thì họ đều phải có
những cái thu tính này. Được chưa? Đấy
là về cái thuộc tính, về cái attribute.
Cái thứ hai là gì? Chúng ta phải định
nghĩa xem những cái hành vi mà mọi người
có thể làm. một người họ có thể ăn ngủ,
nghỉ chơi, làm việc đúng không? Đánh
pick kiểu kiểu như vậy. Được chưa? Đấy.
[khịt mũi] Tức là gì? Tức là khi chúng
ta định nghĩa một chúng ta định nghĩa
một cái class, chúng ta đang định nghĩa
xem là các cái thực thể, các cái đối
tượng thuộc về class này thì họ sẽ có
những cái đặc điểm gì, họ sẽ có những
cái thu tính gì và họ sẽ có những cái
hành động hay là họ có những cái ờ
phương thức gì, cái phương thức gì, đúng
không? Phương thức là những cái hành
động nó mà một đối tượng nó có thể làm.
Được chưa? Thế thì sau khi mà các bạn có
cái bản thiết kế này rồi, ví dụ các bạn
có một cái bản thiết kế về xe ô tô rồi
thì các bạn có thể tạo ra được vô số cái
xe ô tô. Được chưa? Một khi các bạn đã
có một cái bản thiết kế về xe ô tô rồi,
các bạn có thể tạo ra được vô số những
cái xe ô tô. Ví dụ các bạn có bả có bản
thiết kế về xe ô tô thì các bạn có thể
tạo ra cái xe ô tô Audi, xe Nissan, xe
Volvo, xe BMW, xe Mercedes đúng không?
Hoặc các bạn có một cái cá là người rồi
các bạn có thể tạo ra được ông A, ông
Nguyễn Văn A, bà Nguyễn Thị B vân vân
vân vân kiểu kiểu như vậy. Được chưa?
Cái đây chính là khái niệt về về class
và object hay là lớp và đối tượng. Lớp
là cái bản thiết kế kỹ thuật, một cái
bản thiết kế lý thuyết của một cái loại
đối tượng nào đấy. Và sau khi các bạn có
cái bản thiết kế này rồi, các bạn có thể
tạo ra được vô số những cái thực thể, vô
số những cái object, vô số những cái đối
tượng thuộc về cái class này. Được chưa?
Đấy là khái niệm của lớp và đối tượng.
Lớp là cái lý thuyết, đối tượng là cái
thực thể thực tế. Muốn có đối tượng thì
các bạn phải có cái bản vẽ đã. Các bạn
phải có cái lý thuyết đã. đúng không?
Thì đây là hai cái khái niệm cơ bản
trong lộ trình có đối tượng.
Thế thì bây giờ ấy tôi mà ốp cái này vào
trong Docker nó cũng y chang như vậy.
Trong Docker ấy thì chúng ta sẽ có chúng
ta sẽ có hai khái niệm.
Một là docker image. Image là ảnh đấy.
Và hai là docker container. Được chưa?
Có hai khái niệm nhá. Một là bút mình
đâu ấ nhỉ?
Cân bút thì bay đu ngồi viết chay. Vậy
chúng ta sẽ có hai niệm. Một là chúng ta
sẽ có là docker image
và hai là chúng ta sẽ có là docker
container. Được chưa?
Cái docker image ý thì vai trò của nó nó
tương đương với
class
trong khi docker container thì vai sổ nó
tương đương với object.
Được chưa?
Docker image và Docker container. Nhưng
mà trước khi nói về image và do
container nó là cái gì tiết thì mình sẽ
nói việc là vì sao chúng ta cần phải có
docker.
Thì vừa nãy lúc đầu mình có nói với các
bạn là gì? Là trong cái khóa này đúng
không? Chúng ta code là chúng ta code
solo một mình. Khi bạn code một mình thì
thì các bạn code rồi các bạn cài thư
viện cho máy các bạn luôn. Ví dụ các bạn
cài các bạn cài pandas này, các bạn cài
map of plit này, các bạn cài open cv
này, các bạn cài n các bạn cài trên máy
của bạn. Sau các bạn code trên máy, các
bạn chạy trên máy bạn thì quan tâm bình
thường. Nhưng bạn thưởng tượng này.
Nhưng mà bây giờ sau này các bạn đi làm
ấy, các bạn làm xong sản phẩm các bạn
bán cho khách hàng thì các bạn sẽ phải
làm sao các bạn chạy được sản phẩm đấy
trên máy của khách đúng không? Tôi bán
sản phẩm cho khách thì chạ bây giờ tôi
lại bê nguyên cái PC của tôi đưa cho
khách à đúng không? Hay là tôi lại bê
nguyên cái laptop tôi tôi đưa cho khách
à? Đúng không? Là phải làm sao các bạn?
Làm sao các bạn chạy được sản phẩm của
các bạn nhưng mà trên cái platform trên
cái nền tảng của họ thì nó mới ăn tiền
đúng không?
Thì bây gi vấn đề là gì? Là bây giờ lúc
trước ấy để chạy được code trên máy của
mình ấy các bạn vẫn đã cài tỷ thư viện
rồi. Các bạn có dữ liệu, các bạn có thư
viện cài cắm các thứ rồi. Thế bây giờ
dòng máy của khách hàng biết làm thế nào
bây giờ? Tôi lại ngồi tôi chở mông tôi
cài từng thư viện một à đúng không? Lại
rất là khó. Tại vì sao? Nó sẽ có những
trường hợp này. Trường hợp là thứ nhất
là cái
môi trường của máy của bạn có thể sẽ
khác với máy của khách. Môi trườngở đây
là bao gồm những cái gì? Qu tr bao gồm
th nhất là cái hệ điều hành. Ví dụ ở đây
mình dùng Windows, mình cài thêm Windows
đúng không? Nhưng mà khách hàng lại
không dùng Windows, họ dùng Linux. Ví dụ
họ dùng umu chẳng hạn, họ có ông dùng
umu 22.04 có ai có ông lại dùng umu
24.04 đúng không? Thế thì nó sẽ có cái
trường hợp là có thể có những cái thư
viện cài trong hệ điều hành này thì ok
nhưng cài trên hệ điều hành khác nó lại
không ok. hoặc là cũng cái thư viện đấy
mà trong hệ điều hành này nó thì cái cú
pháp tức là nó sẽ cần cái phiên bản
khác. Vệ khác nó sẽ cần phiên bản khác.
Được chưa? Đấy và khi mà cái hệ đường
hành nó không giống nhau rồi thì mọi
những thứ khác nó sẽ có thể có những cái
size số nó sẽ có những sai lệch. Tức là
nhiều khi là cài trên máy này thì cài
các cái thư viện cài cái thư viện đấy.
Cài cái phiên bản ở đấy trên máy này thì
ok nhưng máy của khách lại không ok. Mà
các bạn thấy là các bạn sẽ có rất nhiều
khách bây giờ mỗi ông có ông đấy dùng ma
có ông đấy dùng Windows, có ông dùng Win
10, ông dùng Win 11, có ông dùng 22.04,
22.04, 24.4 mỗi ông cà kiểu như vậy. Bây
giức tôi vào từng ông tôi lại điều chỉnh
cho từng ông một được. Nó rất là phức
tạp đúng không? Thế thì bây giờ người ta
phải cách là gì? Bây giờ ta phải tìm
cách là gì? Bây giờ tức là những project
của mình ấy mình xây dựng xong rồi, mình
chạy máy của mình xong rồi mình phải có
cách làm sao để mình có thể mình đóng
gói cái project lại. Đóng gói có nghĩa
là gì? đóng gói có nghĩa là bây giờ tôi
sẽ đặt tất cả những cái thứ ví dụ như là
hệ điều hành này, thư viện này, ờ hệ
điều hành này, thư viện này, dữ liệu cần
nếu có này rồi squip các thứ các bạn
phải gói hết lại vào trong một cái bọc
được chưa? Gói lại trong một cái bọc.
Rồi sau này ấ muốn triển khai cho khách
nào ấy thì các bạn chỉ cần các bạn mở ấ
các bạn đem cái bọc này đến cái chỗ
khách hàng các bạn mở nó ra rồi các bạn
dùng. Thế thôi. Giống như kiểu này bây
giờ ấy cái ông mà bán hàng phở ấy ông
đấy không thể là bây giờ cứ có khách nào
đến khách nào muốn muốn mua đồ ăn phở
ông ấy lại lọ mọ ấy chạy đến nhà của
khách ông đấy ngồi ông đấy bưng rạp ra
ông đấy nấu đúng không? Ông ấy sẽ phải
làm gì? Ông ấy sẽ phải cho hết những cái
đồ ví dụ thịt này phở cho hết nước dùng
các thứ hành hẹ các thứ rau rước các thứ
ở trong một cái túi cái ông khách ông
đấy mua thì ông đấy chỉ cầm cái túi đấy
đem về nhà ông đấy xong đấy mở xong đấy
đổ ra bát là ăn đúng không? Đấy thì
Docker này nó cũng y chang như vậy. Bây
giờ các bạn muốn triển khai cho khách
hàng, các bạn muốn chỉ khai cho khách
hàng chạy 1000 máy khác nhau thì bả cách
bạn sao các bạn đóng gói cái sản phẩm
lại để làm sao? Bây giem cho khách hàng
tôi sẽ mở ra tôi dùng thế thôi. Được
chưa? Thì đấy là ý của Docker. Các bạn
sẽ phải đóng gói cái môi trường bao gồm
hệ điều hành này, thư viện này, các phải
đóng gói dữ liệu này, các bạn phải đóng
gói cái script Python hoặc là JavaScript
là bất kỳ ngôn ngữ gì các bạn đóng gói
hết lại cái gói đến đấy ra mở bung ra
các bạn xài thôi. Được chưa?
Thế thế thì bây giờ ấy, bây giờ trong
docker nó sẽ có hai khái niệm. Một là
docker image, hai là docker container.
Image là cái ảnh, container là cái là
cái chỗ chứa. Image là tương đương với
class còn container nó tương đương với
cái object. Vai trò của docker image là
cái gì? Là trong cái docker image này
các bạn sẽ phải định nghĩa ra là để chạy
được cái chương trình hay là cái ứng
dụng của các bạn nó có thể là gì? Nó có
thể là một cái trang web, nó có thể là
một cái sản phẩm AI, nó có thể một cái
whatever. Được chưa?
Để có thể chạy được cái chương trình hay
là cái ứng dụng hay là cái gì đấy của
các bạn thì các bạn sẽ cần dùng hệ điều
hành gì? Các bạn cần cái thư viện gì?
Các bạn cần dữ liệu gì? Các bạn cần
script gì? Script tức là những cái file
Python JavaScript các thứ nếu cần đấy
đúng không? Bạn phải chỉ ra tất cả mọi
thứ các bạn cần để chạy cái project đấy
đúng tất cả mọi thứ có liên quan đúng
không? Từ từ môi trường, từ dữ liệu, từ
whatever tất cả các thứ cần liên quan
các bạn phải chỉ ra trong đấy. Được
chưa? Đấy là cái docker image
nhưng mà đây mới chỉ là cái bản chỉ
trong lý thuyết thôi. Docker image nó
chỉ giống như nó tương đương với class
nó chỉ là lý thuyết thôi. Nhưng mà sau
khi mình có cái cái lý cái lý thuyết này
rồi mình sẽ có thể tạo ra được vô số các
cái docker container. Mỗi một cái docker
container này nó sẽ là một cái thực thể
thực tế được tạo ra cái image này để các
bạn có thể chạy cái project ở bên trong.
Chạy project chạy ứng dụng bạn bên
trong. Đấy được chưa? Đấy là khái niệm
về docker container được chưa? container
các bạn chạy ứng dụng biểu bên trong.
Thì bây giờ các bạn sau khi các bạn đính
âm cái docker image rồi các bạn có thể
chạy được vô số container ở vô số máy
khác nhau. Cách A các bạn chạy 100
container, cách B các bạn chạy 200 cái
tất cả sẽ đều dẫn suất từ cái docker
image đầu tiên đúng không? Muốn có
container thì phải có docker image. Cũng
giống như kiểu là muốn có object thì
phải có class trước đấy. Được chưa?
Docker image là nơi các bạn định nghĩa
xem các bạn có những cái gì. Còn
container các bạn sẽ định nghĩa là những
thứ nó sẽ chạy như thế nào. Được chưa?
Rồi
có khó hiểu quá không nhỉ?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không? Mình cũng
không biết nói như vậy liệu các bạn có
hình dung được không? Vai trò đã có
image nó tương đương với class vai trò
đã có container nó tương đương với
object. Thế được chưa? Thứ nhất tức là
gì? Bây giờ ấy tôi muốn chạy cái sản
phẩm A2 của tôi, tôi muốn chạy cái sản
phẩm game của tôi, tôi muốn chạy sản
phẩm web của tôi ở máy của khách hàng
thì bây giờ tôi phải định nghĩa ra một
cái docker image. Docker image này các
bạn phải chỉ ra là các bạn cần những cái
gì để các bạn chạy được trên máy khách
hàng. Sau khi các bạn chỉ ra được rồi,
các bạn có thể chạy vô số máy khác nhau.
Mỗi máy các bạn lại tạo ra một cái
container. Ông A cần chạy gì? Tôi chạy
ông tạo ra một cái container từ docker
image của tôi. Tôi chạy ông ông A. Ông B
cần cái gì? Tôi lại chạy một cái docker
container từ docker image của ông B à từ
cái doc image gốc của tôi cứ làm tương
tự như vậy. Tương tự như vậy. Đấy.
Tiếp. Thế thì có nghĩa là gì? Có nghĩa
là bây giờ cái cái key point là tôi phải
tạo ra được tôi phải định nghĩa ra được
cái docker image của tôi. Nó là cái bản
lý thuyết. Thế thì bây giờ ấy để có thể
tôi chỉ ra được cái document này tôi sẽ
có những cái gì thì tôi sẽ cần lại có
thêm một cái khái niệm nữa là một cái
gọi là một cái gọi là docker file.
Doc docker file.
Docker file là cái file mà tôi sẽ dùng
để tôi chỉ ra là cái doc image tôi nó
được định nghĩa như thế nào. Được chưa?
file của tôi định chỉ là cái document
thôi. Định nghĩa như nào thế?
Đây tôi có ba cái docker file để định
nghĩa cái docker image. Docker image tôi
sẽ dùng để tôi định nghĩa xem là tôi
muốn chạy cái project này tôi cần có
những cái gì? Tôi cần có thư viện gì,
môi trường gì, file gì, d liệu gì. Rồi
tôi sẽ phải tạo ra được vô số doer
container từ cái docker image này. Đấy,
không chỉ dùng cho AI, trong web, trong
game trong app người ta cũng trong web
trong game trong app người ta cũng phải
làm như này đóng gói lại đúng không? Để
bây giờ tôi sau này tôi muốn chuyển hai
trái quai cũng dễ. Còn một cái đặc điểm
nữa là gì? là khi các bạn dùng Docker
này ấ kể cả nhá bây giờ mình đang dùng
Windows đúng không? Mình đang dùng
Windows nhưng mà mình biết là gì? Là
khách hàng của mình họ dùng U2 thì mình
sẽ tạo ra những cái docker image chạy
trên U2
đúng không? Mình biết là khách sẽ dùng
thì mình sẽ tạo ra cái document cũng
chạy hệ thành UM2 luôn. Tức là gì? đang
dùng Windows nhưng tôi có thể tạo ra do
chạy unto chạy chạy win chạy max muốn
chạy cái gì thì chạy đấy và một cái đặc
điểm nữa là này là khi mà các bạn dùng
doer image ấy sau này các bạn mà các bạn
có cái docker image này các container ấy
các bạn muốn chạy thử nghiệm một cái gì
đấy ví dụ các bạn sợ nó hỏng máy chẳng
hạn các bạn cứ nhảy vào trong container
các bạn làm hỏng thì cũng chỉ hỏng cái
container xóa đi là xong chư nó không
ảnh hưởng đến máy của bạn được chưa
trong container nó sẽ nó là một cái môi
trường isolate nó một cái môi trường
cách ly nó độc lập với cái môi trường
chính của chúng ta đấy. Đấy,
thế nói là như vậy. Thế bây giờ ấy thật
ra bình thường ấy bình thường thì khi
mình dùng Docker mình không bao gi mình
dùng trên Windows
mình sẽ dùng trên UM2. Mình dùng trên UM
thế nhưng mà ở đây tôi cho đang dùng
Windows rồi thì và với những bạn nào mà
các bạn mình nghĩ là lớp mình hầu hết
các bạn sẽ quen dùng Windows hơn đúng
không các bạn? Chắc là ở đây các bạn sẽ
ít bạn các bạn biết dùng các bạn dùng
Linux và các bạn dùng U2 đúng không? Thế
thì bây giờ với Windows ấy để cho dễ
tiếp cận, dễ dùng ấy thì người ta có một
cái công cụ người ta gọi là Docker
Desktop giúp các bạn kéo thả nó dễ hơn.
Mình mình chả giống bao giờ cả tại vì
mình dùng chế um thì không thì thì không
cài không phải không cài được mà người
ta không cần người ta sẽ qua dòng lệnh
hết. Thế nhưng mà với các bạn để cho các
bạn dễ tiếp cận thì chúng ta cũng sẽ là
dùng cái docker desktop đấy nhá. Dùng
rất là dễ thôi các bạn. Gõ vào đây nhá.
Gõ vào đây nhá. Docker này desktop nhá.
Được chưa? giúp bạn kéo thải nó dễ. Các
bạn click vào đây. Mình thấy là là mình
cài rồi để phải Discord nào. Locker. Ừ.
Mình
mình cài chưa ấy nhỉ?
Mình cài rồi.
Mình mình cài rồi. Thôi không sao. Mình
cài rồi mình sẽ xóa mình cài cùng các
bạn nhá.
Đây
mình thì mình cài rồi đâ n container đâu
ấy nhỉ? Cái này do desktop mình cài rồi
mình sẽ xóa đi xóa đi cài cùng với các
bạn nhá.
Đây nó xóa các bạn chờ tí mình mình
xóa xong xong mình mình ngồi mình cải
cùng các bạn được chưa đâu xong rồi bay
rồi được chưa đấy các bạn vào các bạn gõ
docker desktop rồi các bạn vào kết quả
đầu tiên docker desktop the top one on
content content software for developer
and teams được chưa các bạn click vào
cái download này click vào được chưa nó
các bạn chọn phiên bản này ví dụ hầu hết
các bạn sẽ dùng các bạn dùng Windows các
bạn dùng cái chọn cái 64 này nhá được
chưa hầu hết các bạn dùng đây
Các bạn dùng Linux các thứ này các bạn
dùng to red các thứ các bạn chụ chọn đây
được chưa? Mình dùng Windows mình dùng
cái trên cùng này
đây.
Load nó về như này
mình có rồi nó mới có cái số 1 này
download đã load về nhá.
6 m 7 máy m đấy. Được chưa?
Nó loot xong thì bây giờ mình chạy thôi.
Vậy chờ tí này.
Ơ
sao nhỉ?
À xong rồi này. Xong rồi
nhá. Click vào thôi.
Đây như thế này
chứ mình click hai lần thì vậy
đây nhá. Ấn văn văn nhá.
Nãy chỉ cho các bạn là các bạn muốn a
các bạn nhìn nhá. Lúc các bạn vào nó sẽ
có cái option này. Các bạn cứ để nguyên
như vậy thôi. Được chưa? Tạo thêm một
cái shortcut ở ngoài desktop nữa. Được
chưa? Ok nhá. Ok. Này
nó sẽ bằng cửa sổ nó hỏi yes hay no các
bạn cài thôi. Đây này.
Đây các bạn cứ cài này. Được chưa? Cái
này thật ra sao? Các bạn làm quen các
bạn dùng quen rồi các bạn sẽ không cần
phải dùng cái doc desktop này đâu. Thế
nhưng mà thôi mới làm quen thì các bạn
dùng cho nó dễ. Được chưa? Các bạn có
cái giao diện kéo thải cảm thấy cho nó
dễ.
Cài một tí các bạn cài cùng mình luôn.
Có gì demo làm là làm thử luôn.
Chờ cay một lúc nhá.
Xong rồi.
Không cần không cần không cần
không cần close nhá. Lâu xong nhá. Các
bạn mở ấn cái nút Windows các bạn mở
docker desktop lên nó sẽ hình con cá
voi.
Khi nào mà cái thanh ở dưới đây các bạn
các bạn chờ tí mình đang mở đây nhá. Lần
đầu khởi động nó sẽ hơi đế bên trên đây
này. Như thế này bạn bước vừa rồi các
bạn mở ấn cái nút window cái nút mà cái
nút mà nằm giữa control về nút add ấy ở
dưới cái thanh dưới cùng ấy đúng không?
gần phím cách ấy, ấn cái nút nút Windows
ấy thì là cái bảng này các bạn ấn accept
vào. Accept này được chưa? Nó như này
đây. Các bạn có thể các bạn skip cái
này. Skip thôi, không cần phải đăng nhập
gì đâu. Skip nhá. Được chưa? Các bạn sẽ
vào một cái giao diện như này. Nhìn nhá.
Cái giao diện này.
Cái giao diện này các bạn nhìn này. Ở
cái thanh bên trái á, ở thanh bên trái
các bạn sẽ có rất nhiều mục như này. Thế
thì hiện tại các bạn chỉ chú ý hai mục
là images và container.
Hiện tại các bạn chả có cái gì cả.
Images cũng chả có, container cũng chả
có. Thì tất nhiên rồi, mới cài mà mới
cài thì lấy lấy lấy đâu ra mà có. Được
chưa? Thì bây giờ chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu
chúng ta sẽ làm quen. Làm quen để các
bạn thấy là các cái khái niệm như là
docker file, docker image và docker
container có ý nghĩa là gì. Được chưa?
Làm quen nhá. Thì đầu tiên này các bạn
có một cái mục là how do I run a
container. Được chưa nhá. Click vào đây.
Có hai cái mục này các bạn chỉ hỏi cái
nhá. Iron container nhìn nhá. Được chưa?
Thì các bạn nhìn này, các bạn thấy là ở
ngay đầu tiên này nó có một cái hình
minh họa này. Cái hình minh họa này nó
chính là cái hình nó thể hiện cái mối
quan hệ giữa docker file, docker image
và docker container. Được chưa? Docker
file, docker image và doer container.
Cái docker file ấy sẽ là cái ông mà định
nghĩa docker image.
Còn ông image là cái ông để tạo ra được
container. Đây tí mình sẽ cho các bạn
xem thử luôn từng ông một có ý nghĩa như
nào nhá. Tầng hầu một bây giờ các bạn
chưa có cái gì cả. Chưa có cái gì cả.
Các bạn chưa có docker file, các bạn
chưa có docker image và các bạn càng
không có docker container. Đúng không?
Bây giờ sẽ từng cái một. Phải có docker
file mới có docker image. Có docker
image mới tạo ra được nhiều docker
container. Mỗi do container chạy ở một
chỗ khác nhau. Được chưa? Thế đầu tiên
đầu tiên các bạn có thể ấn next và các
bạn nhìn dưới này. Đây nó sẽ có một cái
report này. Như mình copy mình gửi cho
các bạn này. Được chưa? Cái report này
ấy à đây là cái câu lệnh nó luôn git
clone. Các bạn có thể các bạn
các bạn các bạn nhìn nhá. Về đây mình
mình sẽ làm mẫu và các bạn mở cái
terminal ra được chưa các bạn? Mở
terminal này các bạn sẽ gõ mình là
bạn nào các bạn có git rồi các bạn làm
như này chờ tí nhá. Đây nhá. Git clone
mình paste y hệt này. Paste này được
chưa? Gõ này enter là được.
Enter là được.
Thế nhưng mà có thể trong lớp có lớp có
thể có bạn là các bạn chưa cài git, các
bạn chưa cài git thì các bạn sẽ không
chạy được cái dòng lệnh này thì các bạn
có thể cài git thì cũng được nhưng mà
mình có một cách khác nó đơn giản hơn là
gì? Bây giờ các bạn vào cái report này
các bạn click vào cái link này nhá.
Click vào cái link này. Đấy nó vào đây
nó sẽ hiện ra một cái giao diện này.
Được chưa? Thì cái giao diện này ấy các
bạn có cái nút là code này. Các bạn
click vào cái code này. Các bạn ấn nút
các bạn ấn cái download zip này là xong.
Được chưa? Ấn code đây. Xong bạn ấn
download zip xong nó sẽ tải một cái file
về các bạn giải nén ra y chang nó cũng
ná ná như thế được chưa? Nhưng mà mình
thì mình git clone về rồi nó sẽ có một
cái thư mục như này đâ. Mình sẽ có cái
thư mục là ở đâu rồi?
Đây welcome to docker
được chưa? Welcome to docker đấy cái
welcome toer này chính là cái mình vừa
clone về đây này. Đây vừa clone về này.
Welcome to docker được chưa? Thế thì
trong cái thư mục này các bạn nhìn thấy
ngay nó một cái file là docker file. Đây
đây chính là khởi nguồn của mọi thứ.
Docker file mình mở ra nhá. Do file. Cái
file nó nó nó như thế này.
Bây giờ cái docker file này như mình vừa
nói rồi. Đây chính là nơi chúng ta định
nghĩa cái docker image của chúng ta.
Được chưa? Docker file là nơi mà chúng
ta định nghĩa ra cái docker image của
chúng ta.
Docker file nó có những cái gì thì các
bạn nhìn đây. Đầu tiên này
các bạn mà học lập trình hướng đối tượng
rồi các bạn sẽ biết là gì? Là khi mà
chúng ta thiết kế lớp ấy, khi chúng ta
thiết kế class ấy, chúng ta sẽ hiếm khi
mà chúng ta thiết kế một cái một cái
class hoàn toàn từ đầu đúng không? Chúng
ta sẽ rất hiếm khi chúng ta thiết kế một
cái class mới tin từ đầu mà chúng ta
thường chúng sẽ làm gì? Chúng ta sẽ xem
là có cái ông nào ông đấy đã thiết kế
một cái class nó đã tương đối hoàn
thiện, nó đã tương đối sát với những cái
gì mình cần rồi. Ví dụ như này,
bây giờ mình muốn thiết kế một cái xe ô
tô đúng không? Nhưng mà bây giờ ấy mình
mà phải tự thiết kế xe ô tô từ đầu ấy nó
lại rất là mệt và tốn thời gian.
Bây giờ mình sẽ xem là có ông nào ông
đấy đã thiết kế một cái thứ gọi là một
cái phương tiện giao thông đúng không?
Ông nào ông đấy đã thiết kế một cái lớp
gọi là lớp phương tiện giao thông rồi
thì bây giờ tôi sẽ chỉ tôi làm sao tôi
dựa vào cái bản thiết kế của ông đấy.
Tôi modify, tôi biến đổi, tôi làm
whatever để tôi điều chỉnh nó để cho nó
phù hợp với hơn với cái bài toán của tôi
đúng không? Thì trên này trong lập trình
hướng tượng người ta gọi là kế thừa,
đúng không? Gọi là inheritance đúng
không? Kế thừa tức là gì? kế thừa giống
như kiểu là bây giờ bố mình có cái gì
thì mình kế thừa mình làm tiếp đấy thôi.
Bố mình có một bố mình có 10 tỷ chẳng
hạn đúng mình cầm đúng 10 tỷ đấy mình
mình mình xây dựng cơ nghiệp đúng không
chứ mình xây dựng đầu gì cho khổ ra đúng
không đây nó cũng như vậy đúng không thì
bây giờ ấy trong cơ nó cũng y chang
trước chúng ta ấy đã có một cộng đồng
rất là lớn đ cộng đồng những cái de
những cái software họ đã thiết kế đến
rất nhiều những cái docker image rồi
chúng ta nên tận dụng những cái docker
image mà những người đi trước người ta
tạo ra rồi
để tránh cái việc các bạn phải cố lệ tự
đầu. Ví dụ như này,
bây giờ ví dụ mình mình muốn xây dựng
cái project về Python đúng không? Bây
giờ mình phải ngồi mình cài đặt từng thứ
nào các bạn cài u cài u là cài Windows
rồi các bạn cài Python rồi các bạn cài
thư viện tư rất làng nó rất là lâu. Tôi
sẽ xem là có trước đây có cái ông nào
mới đã tạo ra một cái docker image mà nó
đã hao hao cái mà tôi cần hay không thì
tôi sẽ dựa vào đấy đúng không? Thì các
bạn nhìn đây cái dòng đầu tiên này form
Note 22 đây này. Đây chính là cái dòng
nó tương đương với việc chúng ta đang kế
thừa từ một cái lớp tra trong l trình
hướng đối tượng là truyền thượng chúng
ta có lớp tra lớp con không? Lớp con kế
thừa lớp tra thì đây y chang như vậy.
Cái dòng này chính là lúc chúng ta gì?
Chúng ta sẽ muốn là chúng ta sẽ cái
docker image của chúng ta ấy nó sẽ kế
thừa từ một cái base image này đúng
không? Kế thừa có nghĩa là gì? là cái
base image này nó có cái gì thì cái
image của tôi mặc định nó cũng sẽ có
đúng những cái đấy được chưa? Nó sẽ có
đúng y chang cái đấy. Sau các bạn muốn
thêm sắc gì các bạn thêm sau được chưa?
Thế cái dòng đầu tiên nhá. Thế bây giờ
ấy làm sao để làm sao để tôi biết là
cộng đồng họ đã tạo ra những cái gì rồi?
Cái tên này lấy từ đâu mà ra? Thì các
bạn nhìn đây
trên Internet chúng ta có một cái trang
gọi là Docker Hub
trung tâm cái zốn đúng không? Trung tâm
cái zốn đúng không? Docker Hub. Docker
Hub này là nơi mà người ta đã tổng hợp
và người ta đã chia sẻ rất nhiều những
docker image mà cộng đồng phát triển từ
trước này ở mọi mảng, mọi lĩnh vực, mọi
nền tảng. Được chưa? Các bạn cũng chả
cần phải in gì đâu. Vào thôi. Bây giờ ví
dụ nhá. Ở đây các bạn nhìn thấy đây các
bạn có cái là se doer hub. Ví dụ đi bạn
nào mà các bạn học tiếc cái khóa sau các
bạn học về cái khóa về deep learning for
computer các bạn sẽ biết một cái
framework là framework Python là cái
framework người ta dùng trong người ta
dùng để người ta phải lập trình cái mạng
neuron rồi những cái mạng non tích chập
các thứ new network rồi CNN các thứ đúng
không? Mình sẽ gõ là Python
hoặ mình vào khóa này đi chúng ta có si
cái lon chứ gì cái lon này đây cái lon
này được chưa sơn đấy các bạn nh rất
nhiều s cái l mình gõ ví dụ là mình gõ
nhá nhìn này đây python này pyt này được
chưa hoặc lăng trên đ bạn nào học khóa
em lăng trên
rất nhiều được chưa rất nhiều đúng không
thế hoặc bây giờ mình muốn là có một cái
docker image của hệ đu hành um đây
umbunu này umbuntu Window được chưa? Đây
mình đang dùng Windows nhưng mình muốn
dùng hệ bánh U mình sẽ dùng đây nó sẽ có
cái vào những cái ký hiệu đây các bạn
nhìn cái ký hiệu ý nghĩa nó ở dưới này.
Đấy được chưa? Thông thường ý thường thự
ra là thường cái ông nào mà cái số lược
mà tải về đây đây nó hơn 1 tỷ lượt tải
này nó hơn 100.000 star các thứ à hơn
1000 star này các bạn thấy là cái này nó
cứ càng nhiều thì nó càng đáng tin cậy
thôi. Càng nhiều nó lại càng đáng tin
cậy đấy.
Càng nhiều càng đáng tin cậy thế. Hoặc
bây giờ các bạn muốn là vừa có UM2 vừa
có Python. Đây UM2 này bọ th Python vào
đây
thì đây
đây được chưa?
vừa gần đây hoặc là các bạn có muốn ô
các bạn có cả JavaScript nào. JavaScript
JS nà.
Đây là nút JS đây cũng phải to không
phải vào sau viết được
đâ đúng không? Đại loại là như vậy. Ví
dụ nhá các bạn nhìn trong cái trường hợp
này ví dụ là cái file ví dụ là cái đ nhá
note này 22 cái note này nó là cái tên
cái tên của cái docker imra các bạn mình
gõ note thôi nhá note này được chưa
trong cái note đây các bạn đây này note
này được chưa trong cái note này lại có
nhiều cái phiên lại có nhiều những cái
tag t này nó nó kiểu là phiên bản 1.12
1.3 đấy 2.1 2 23 đây nó y chang như vậy
note này 22 này cái tag này các bạn cái
tag này đây này đấy cái tag đây các bạn
có thể gõ vào đây ví dụ mình gõ mình
cũng không code javascript bao giờ mình
chả biết nó cái gì 22 này hoặc là
à pá được chưa nên là có rất nhiều phiên
bản được chưa 22
22 trừ này đây ví dụ đây
được chưa đấy xong các bạn dựa vào cái
tên thôi đây này dựa vào cái tên đây
Đấy. Được chưa? Tên này copy nguyên tên
này là xong. Đấy. Tên của cái docker
image và tên cái phiên bản của nó. Tại
vì cùng một doer image nó sẽ có rất
nhiều phiên bản đây. Bạn nh các bạn ấy t
các bạn thấy có một hàng xa số phiên bản
nhiều lắm. Đây này. Đúng tất nhiều tag
giống kiểu version thôi. 1.1 1.2 1.3
kiểu như vậy. Được chưa? Đấy. Ở đây thì
ví dụ đây người ta dùng cái docker cái
doer image kế thừa từ cái ông này. Được
chưa? Cái dòng này là gần như cái docker
file nào nó cũng có cái nó có cái dòng
này. Tại vì sao? Tại vì chúng ta sẽ
không bao giờ chúng ta muốn là chúng ta
phải ngồi chúng ta gõ code từ đầu không
bao gi chúng ta muốn chúng ta phải ngồi
chúng ta thiết kế doc image từ đầu mà
chúng ta sẽ kế thừa cái doc image này.
Được chưa?
Tiếp cái này thì nó có ý nghĩa là gì?
Cái cái dòng tiếp theo này nó có ý nghĩa
các bạn chú ý những cái comment nó chỉ
là comment thôi nhá. Comment nó giống
như lập trình thôi. Nó chỉ là để cho nó
rõ thôi. Được chưa? Cái work de này nó
là cái gì? Work đi v của working
directory. Tức là đây là cái thư mục
chúng ta sẽ làm việc ở trên đấy. Tức là
các bạn tưởng tượng là khi mà các bạn
dùng docker image và docker container
ấy, docker container nó sẽ tạo ra một
cái môi trường độc lập với môi trường
máy của chúng ta. Ví dụ máy chúng ta nó
có ổ C, ổ D, ổ E gì đúng không? Máy
chúng ta có ổ C, ổ D, ổ E thì nếu mà cái
docker container ấy nó được tạo ra từ
một cái docker image của Windows ấy thì
nó cũng sẽ có ổ C, ổ D, ổ E. Thì cái chỗ
này các bạn sẽ chỉ ra là các bạn đang
muốn làm việc ở cái thư mục nào. Đây có
thể thư mục ví dụ là Windows các bạn nó
có thể thư mục download, thư mục
document, thư mục ổ CD ổ e gì đấy. Còn
nếu mà các bạn dùng hệ hành UTU chẳng
hạn thì nó sẽ có những cái thư mục khác
đúng không? Tức là nó chính là nó chính
là
ờ đây này, nó chính là những cái thư mục
để chúng ta máy chúng ta các bạn mình có
rất nhiều thư mục đây nó cũng y chang
như vậy. Nó cũng sẽ có rất nhiều thư mục
như vậy. Mình phải chỉ ra là mình sẽ
muốn làm việc ở cái thư mục nào. Được
chưa?
Tiếp này. Tiếp theo thì bây giờ ấy khi
mình muốn tạo ra một cái docker image để
sau này nó sẽ sinh ra những cái do
container ấy thì mình sẽ có những cái
file trong máy của mình hiện tại mình
muốn copy vào bên trong container. Được
chưa? Mình có những file trong máy của
mình ví dụ đây mình có những cái file
mình có cái file C mình có cái file mấy
cái file CSV này, file Excel này mình
muốn copy chúng nó copy vào bên trong
của container được chưa? Mình muốn copy
vào bên trong của container thì mình sẽ
làm như này. Được chưa? Máy mình bây giờ
trong cái report này nó có những cái
file nào mà cái tên bắt đầu là bằng
package gì đấy chjon
thì mình sẽ copy nó vào bên trong của
container mình sẽ copy ở trong thư mục
app này được chưa? Copy vào bên trong
app.
Ví dụ bây gi mình có về cái project về
Python cái project mình chạy sa mình
phải copy file của mình vào chứ thì nó
mới chạy chứ đúng không? Không có script
thì lấy lấy cái gì mà chạy được chưa?
Thì đây nó có những cái file tration này
nội dung chả biết nó có cái gì đây file
như này được chưa mình muốn copy và vào
bên trong thì mình dùng cái này được
chưa tôi copy từng nguồn là cái file
trên máy của tôi vào đên
trong container đấy được chưa tôi c muốn
copy nhiều thứ nữa. Tôi muốn copy cái
thư mục sort này public này
short này. Public này được chưa?
Sau đó tôi sẽ muốn cài các cái thư viện.
Tức là ở cái notốe cha này
ở cái docker image chara này ấ nóã có
một vài nó đã có nhiều thứ rồi nhưng rõ
ràng tôi vẫn muốn cài thêm một vài cái
thứ khác nữa. Tôi muốn tôi muốn cài thêm
một vài thư viện các thứ chẳng hạn thì
tôi sẽ dùng cái câu lệnh run. Run này
chính là câu lệnh các bạn có thể các bạn
cài đặt thư viện. Ví dụ là bây giờ mình
dùng một cái docker image mà nó có sơn
rồi, nó có m rồi nhưng mà nó lại thiếu
open cv thì mình sẽ cài thêm open cv
bằng cái câu lệnh này. Được chưa? Câu
lệnh này hay câu lệnh run này đúng
không? Run các bạn chạy ở nhiều dòng nó
có cái dấu xộc xuống dưới này. Tiếp mình
có một cái dòng nữa là dòng expo. Cái
dòng này thường nó sẽ dùng cho những ứng
dụng liên quan đến web. Vì sao lại có
cái dòng expo này? Thì các bạn hiểu này,
ứng dụng về web ấy thường nó sẽ cần phải
ví dụ các bạn chạy một cái server, các
bạn chạy một cái web ở trên một cái
server đúng không? Các bạn sẽ phải có
một cái cổng để các bạn lắng nghe kết
nối từ người dùng đến đúng không? Cái
cổng để lắng nghe những cái request của
người dùng đến chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì
bình thường các bạn trên máy của bạn thì
các bạn sẽ có một cái cổng nó phải mở ra
để nó lắng nghe kết nối đến. Thế nhưng
mà tí nữa các bạn chạy các bạn sẽ tạo ra
container từ cái image này mà cái cổng
của container nó sẽ khác với cổng trên
máy của chúng ta.
Thế bây giờ chúng ta muốn là từ ngoài
chúng ta mà muốn kết nối được đến cái
cổng container ấy thì lúc các bạn tạo ra
cái docker in này các bạn phải có một
cái dòng như này expo tức là gì? Tôi sẽ
l tôi sẽ mở đúng không? Expo là mở nó ra
để để bên ngoài nó tiếp xúc vào. Mở cái
cổng này ra để cái cổng này sẽ chính là
cái cách để các bạn có thể gửi request
đến container được chưa? Gửi request
container các bạn dùng cái này được
chưa? Và sau đó thì cái này chỉ ứng dụng
về là về web, về app. Khi mà các bạn cần
lắng nghe, request người dùng nó gửi đến
và các bạn sử dụng cái gì mà cần phải
dùng đến API ấ thì bạn mới dùng cần cần
cái dòng này.
Cuối cùng các bạn sẽ có một cái câu lệnh
là cmd. CMD là tức là gì? Tức là khi mà
các bạn bắt đầu chạy container ấy thì
đến cuối nó chạy câu lệnh này. Ví dụ các
bạn có câu lệnh là Python
cách classification.pẽ
enter. Ví dụ như vậy các bạn sẽ chỉ ra ở
đây Python đây. Classification.pi Pi này
hoặc là có những cái tham số gì truyền
vào đây. Được chưa? Đấy thì đây là cái
cấu trúc của cái docker file.
Hôm nay chúng ta
nói qua như vậy đi. Mai mai chúng ta sẽ
mai chúng thứ nhất là chúng ta sẽ thực
hành chúng ta sẽ
thật ra bây giờ thực hành mình sẽ thực
hành luôn. Thực hành mình sẽ chạy luôn
để cho các bạn hình dung được xem nó như
nào nhá. Bây giờ sau khi các bạn đã có
cái các bạn đã có các bạn đã git clone
cái report này về rồi thì các bạn nhìn
nhá. Nhìn tiếp này. Bây giờ cái bước
tiếp theo nhá. Bước tiếp theo là gì? Là
bây giờ các bạn sẽ nhìn cái vữ mình vừa
nhìn cái docker file rồi đúng không?
Fify cho docker file các bạn xem rồi
đúng không? Bây gi đầu tiên các bạn sẽ
câu lệnh như này nhá. Muốn mua do mình
phải vào đây đã. CD vào trong Wcam này.
Được chưa? Mình ở trong này rồi đây
mình ở trong cái thư mục này rồi đó.
Mình có cái docker file này rồi. Được
chưa? Thì mình sẽ m câu lệnh như này.
Docker cách vui cách trừ t welcome to
docker chấm một cái docker là tên với từ
khóa. Các bạn muốn làm những cái thứ
liên quan đến docker các bạn phải có cái
từ docker này đi đầu. Được chưa? Bu ở
đây là bu cái gì? Bu ở đây là bucker
image. Đúng tôi đang save một cái docker
image để sau này tôi có thể tạo ra được
vô số container từ cái từ cái image đó.
Được chưa? Tôi lại xame cái docker image
trừ t.
Sau đó là một cái dòng chữ này. Đây là
cái tên của document. Doc nó cũng giống
nó cũng giống như chúng ta vậy. Phải có
một cái định danh cái tên đúng không?
Đây người ta dùng cái tên là W to
docker. Cái tên này vô tình nó đang
trùng với cái tên của folder này nhưng
mà nó không cần thiết. Các bạn hoàn toàn
các bạn có thể dùng cái tên khác. Ví dụ
mình sẽ đặt tên đặt một cái tên là đặt
tên là example được chưa? Thoải mái tên
gì cũng được. Docker tôi sẽ bull một cái
docker image trừ t tôi chỉ là cái tên
của nó. Tôi dấu chấm. Dấu chấm này để
thể hiện gì? Dấu chấm này thể hiện là
tôi sẽ phải tìm ra cái docker file ở cái
thư mục hiện tại. Tôi ở cái thư mục
tcker này. Tôi sẽ phải tìm docker file
cũng nằm trong thư mục này. Được chưa?
Tôi phải tìm ra docker file cũng nằm
trong thư mục này. Được chưa? Như thế
này mà nó mặc định là nó sẽ tìm cái file
tên là docker file. Còn nếu mà các bạn
muốn đổi cái tên này đi thì nó sẽ có
cách khác mà thôi. Lúc đầu các bạn cũng
không cần phải đi quá sâu như vậy. Các
bạn cứ mặc định là gì? Các bạn có mình
một cái file thocker file này. Được
chưa? Docker bui tr- t. Example chấm một
cái này tôi sẽ bu cái docker image từ
cái docker file này. Các bạn chú ý là
trước khi mình mình ấn enter nhá. Nhắc
lại mình vẫn hiện nay mình vẫn hoàn toàn
chống trơn do image chưa có cái gì. Có
th cũng chưa có cái gì. Hai ông đều
trắng tinh. Được chưa? Bây giờ các bạn
nhìn này.
Bây giờ mình mà ấn chạy một cái nhá.
Mình mà enter một cái các bạn nhìn này.
Bên trái đang là docker image chống trơn
đúng không? Bên phải thì như này nhá.
Nhìn này. Enter một cái này.
Được chưa?
Nó sẽ có những dòng vui vui này. Đấy. Nó
vôi. Đây nó có bảy bước. Tại vì sao? Vì
bảy bước này. 1 này. 2 này.
3 này. 4 5 này. 6 7 à.
Mấy cái dòng expo về cái này nó không
tính được chưa? M form các bạn nhá. Đầu
tiên là mình đăng đến bước số bao nhiêu
này đúng không? Hết sáu bước rồi. Bước 7
này. Bước 7 là cái bước mà run đây. Được
chưa? Hai cái cuối nó không tính.
À cái quố điền nó vẫn tính được một bước
này. Được chưa? Hai cuối này nó không
tính
trong lúc chạy nhá.
Bạn chưa xong các bạn chờ một tí.
Nó đang cài đang cài thế này
chưa? Chờ một tí.
Lần đầu thì nó sẽ phải bu image m mới
tinh thì nó sẽ hơi lâu. Còn những lần
sau sẽ nhanh hơn. Đây các bạn nhìn này.
Xong rồi. Xong rồi. Chạy xong rồi nhá.
Bây gi mình mở ra các bạn nhìn này. Đây
thấy chưa? Bữa mình đặt tên nó là
example đây này. Đặt tên là example
chưa? Document là example. Đây là tên
cái tag này là cái version mặc định các
bạn không chỉ ra nó lúc nào nó là let
cuối cùng được chưa? Đây là tên giống
kiểu tên người. Còn đây là giống kiểu
căn cức công dân đấy. Image ID này được
chưa? Căn cứ công dân như này được chưa?
Được tạo ra từ 15 giây trước kích thước
là khoảng nửa GB được chưa? Đấy thì đây
là các bạn tạo ra được một cái doer
image rồi. Được chưa? Sau đó từ cái do
này các bạn thể chạy chạy ra được vô số
do container khác nhau. Được chưa?
Docker image nhá. Container thì vẫn chưa
có. Container vẫn chưa có mà chỉ có
locker image thôi. Được chưa? Các bạn sẽ
có tiếp cái dòng là next này. Các bạn sẽ
có cái dòng là run container nhá. Run
thì mình chỉ có mấy cái run rất là dễ
thôi. Tích vào cái dấu tam giác này
nhá. Cái option setting này. Đầu tiên
các bạn chú ý này. Đầu tiên ấy các bạn
nhớ là cái ứng dụng của mình này. Đây là
một cái ứng dụng của mình nó mở cổng
3000.
Cái cổng 3000 này là cái cổng 3000 của
container mà các bạn sẽ tạo ra. T các
bạn cứ mở các bạn cứ tạo ra container từ
do image nó sẽ lắng nghe ở cổng 3000
này. Thế bây giờ cái cổng 3000 này mình
phải tại vì là cái cổng 3000 này ấy là
nó là cổng của bên trong container. mình
sẽ phải ánh xạ nó với một cái cái cổng
trên máy của mình để sau này nó giống
như kiểu là cái người liên lạc trung
gian ấy đúng không? Tôi muốn liên lạc
với cái ông cổng 3000 tôi phải đi qua
cái ông ở cổng hot này. Tại vì cái cổng
hot này nó nó mới là cái cổng vật lý nó
mới là cái cổng thật. Có cổng 3000 là
cổng bên trong container ứng từ bên
ngoài nó sẽ không không biết đến. Ví dụ
mình mình sẽ ánh sạ đúng cổng 3000 luôn.
Tì máy mình cổng 3000 nó cũng đang rảnh
mà mình ánh sạ hai ông cổng 3000 với
nhau. Được chưa? Cổng 3000 của máy sẽ
đại diện cho cổng 3000 trong container
được chưa? Sau đó mình có thể đặt cái
tên tên các bạn thích đặt gì cũng được
mình đặt tên là Việt AI. Được chưa? Ấn
run. Run một cái này các bạn nhìn đây.
Image đây nhá. Container đây nhá. Được
chưa? Run
đây. Rồi mình mình sẽ mở mình sẽ mở cái
sẽ mở web lên đây. Nó là một cái web này
này. Đấy web này được chưa? Bình thường
web này nó chỉ mở được ở cổng 3000 của
container mình đã ánh sạ cổng 3000
container với cổng máy của mình rồi. Thì
đây mình click vào vào X này nó như này.
Được chưa? Mình click vào linkin nó như
này. Linkin của
link kin của mình chưa? Mình kích vào
redit như này.
Đấy đúng không? Bây giờ các bạn không
các bạn muốn triển khai cho khách hàng
các bạn đâu cần phải ngồi cài thủ công
đâu. Các bạn cứ thếm các bạn chạy thôi.
Đúng không? Một khi bạn đã thiết kế
document rồi các bạn tạo nó vô số
content thôi. Được chưa? Đấy là một cái
ví dụ.
Đây là người ta làm sẵn ra rồi. Được
chưa? Mình muốn tạo nữa thì cũng
đúng rồi. Người ta cũng dùng trong đi
trong deploy server. Một trong số tác
dụng các bạn tạo container này các bạn
để các bạn deploy trên server các bạn
không cần phải cài thủ công từng thứ một
nữa đúng không? Mình tắt đi bây gi mình
có thể mình tạo ra mình tạo ra một cái
đây mình mình có một một cái một cái
container mình tạo ra một cái container
nữa nhá. Run này. Nhưng mà bây giờ ấy
vừa rồi ấy cái container kia ấy nó đã nó
đã được liên kết với cổng 3000 của máy
mình rồi. Bây giờ mình muốn chạy nữa
mình phải liên kết với một cổng khác
3001 chẳng hạn thì mới được. Tại vì cổng
3000 của máy mình bên nó bận cho cái
container kia rồi. Container name các
bạn không chỉ ra nó sẽ tự nó sẽ tạo ra
một cái container mặc định. Run này đây
này. Bây bây gi
flamboyas Robinson này. Được chưa? Nó
nối với cổng 3001.
Đây cổng 3001 này. Đấy cổng 3001 của máy
mình nó được ánh sạ với cái cổng 3000
của cái container này. Được chưa?
Cổng 3001 cái cổng phía trước là 301 là
của máy mình còn 3000 sau là cổng ở bên
trong container các bạn không? Các bạn
có thể tạo ra được 10 trang web đúng
không? Các bạn chạy 10 lần chạy ra 10
trang web được chưa? Mà các bạn không
phải không phải cài thủ công đúng không?
Không phải cài thủ công b các bạn chuyển
chạy các bạn tạo ra đây tất cả các thứ đ
chỉ ở đây hết rồi được chưa?
Rồi
có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có b nào có câu hỏi gì không?
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Hôm nay chúng ta mới dùng cái hàng có
sẵn. Mai chúng ta làm hàng của chúng ta
được chưa? Mai chúng ta sẽ đem cái đống
mấy cái file mấy cái scp lần trước chúng
ta chạy mấy cái mô hình classification
chúng ta đem vào trong docker xem nó
trông như nào nhá.
Ok. Có b nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Ok. Thế mai vẫn giờ này các bạn nhé.
Vẫn gi này nhá. Mai chúng ta sẽ thực
hành được chưa? Lý thuyết rồi. Mai thực
hành nhá.